Honestly, I need you
to take me shopping 'cause I don't...
Like I'm on a TV show now twice a month, fortnightly.
(bright music)
What is happening, all you highly-evolved primates?
My name is Rich Roll.
I appreciate that the illusion of free will has directed you
to our wavelength in this particular time space dimension,
and I hope it finds you loved in a space of gratitude,
in a mindset of gratitude as well.
I wrote that as well, in a space of gratitude
(Adam laughs)
and a mindset of openness and prepared to receive,
because, because I am joined once again
by my favorite edgelord of words, literary of actions,
activist of contributions, environmentalist,
my Waterkeeper comrade and caretaker
of lands, wet and arid, Mr. Adam Skolnick.
Great to be here, Rich.
Once again.
Kudos on that paragraph.
Although I messed it up a little bit.
With double gratitude.
It's okay to double down.
Double, if you're gonna double down on anything,
gratitude is not about-
Gratitude is the way to go.
(Rich laughs)
And I am a highly evolved primate.
As we all are, hopefully with more evolution ahead of us.
Yes.
And I get that reminder every morning
because I have a small primate at home.
Aha.
Yeah.
(Adam laughs)
Less highly evolved, but soon to be evolved,
but it may be more highly evolved.
In some ways more highly evolved.
Yeah (laughs) yes.
We can all learn from the young ones.
Yes (laughs) yes.
Happy to be back with you today.
Last time we appeared together was pretty heavy.
This one's gonna be a little bit lighter
with some flex light-dusting of heaviness in the middle.
Like dusting of we're all gonna die right in the middle.
Yeah (laughs) right.
(Adam laughs)
Just a little thin veneer of existential dread
before we get back to the jocular.
Yes.
Because you know what?
Why not laugh?
While we're all going down the tubes,
is that what you're saying?
This is like-
I am an optimist.
(Adam laughing)
I have confidence in humanity and solving our problems.
I do too.
Before we get into all of that,
for those that are new or newer to this particular corner
of this particular podcast,
"Roll On" is our biweekly, more on that later.
Don't don't think we're not done talking about biweekly.
We got more to say about that.
(Adam laughs)
You're sticking with it.
It is our biweekly momentary movement,
our periodic pivot away
from my traditional "Fare of Evergreen Conversations"
to hone on matters of contemporaneous important.
Today, in the interest
of always playing around with and tweaking the format,
we're gonna do that again, but with a minor twist.
After a bit of our typical ribald banter,
we're gonna indulge you with a brief conversation
with legendary environmental activist
and Arctic swimmer Lewis Pugh, which is exciting,
I think you guys are gonna really enjoy it,
followed by a more at times philosophical discourse on some
of the more important things I've learned
over the nine years of doing this thing, this podcast,
what it is I'm trying to accomplish,
what we can all learn
from what I've learned going through this experience.
And then of course, as always,
we answer a few questions submitted by you guys,
the audience, on our voicemail,
which is get out a pen, everybody, 424-235-4626.
But before Lewis joins us, Adam, how it goes you?
Well, Rich I've been replaced.
I see you across from me right now,
you haven't been replaced yet.
Not by you or Brogan, but by the Malibu Artist.
What happened?
He met Orlando Bloom.
(Rich laughs)
Great.
You've been supplanted as his favorite muse?
I can't even fault him for it, like-
Well, first of all,
explain to people or remind people who the Malibu Artist is.
The Malibu Artist is my friend who's a drone pilot,
and he's got Malibu Artist on Instagram
and YouTube, great channel.
Mm-hmm.
He's one of these like new-school nature videographers
that like has a home on YouTube, does very, very well,
and he is, for the last several years,
gone up and down the coast and shooting sharks in the water
not far from swimmers and surfers.
We've talked about it before.
He's captured me in the water
not far from a white shark where I normally swim,
and he was in Malibu doing one of his recon flights
and Orlando recognized him and came up to him
and they started chatting and Orlando was getting ready
to stand up paddle,
and he's like, "Is there something out there right now?"
And 'cause he's a fan of Carlos, and they found it,
he showed it to him, and next thing you know,
Orlando is out there like kneeling over a white shark
on his board, and they've just hit it off, so yeah,
they've done a couple of different missions together.
Right.
Yeah.
Blake, maybe you can pull up Orlando Bloom's Instagram
where he shares the video that the Malibu artist
has created of him stand up paddle boarding.
While he's looking for that, I think that's funny.
Yeah.
You were a stepping stone in his ascent of fame, right?
Like it's kind of like when a friend of yours starts
a podcast and they ask you to be like one
of the first guests when there's no audience, right?
And then you do it and then you realize like, oh,
I'm just a launchpad for you to get other people.
(Rich laughs)
Right, right.
And by the time there's a big audience,
like you're the guy who was on when no one
was paying attention.
I was OG, like like a conscious shark bait.
He was filming like unwitting swimmers and surfers.
I was like the guy who knew what was going on
and got in there, and now-
Right, you had belief in him early on.
(Adam laughs)
And now you have been discarded, summarily dismissed.
I literally asked, "Hey, I'm going, you wanna meet up?
"I'm about to go for a swim."
He's like, "Oh, I've got Orlando."
I've got Orlando.
We're sorry.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
So here it is, if you're watching on video, Blake,
pull it up.
Is there music on there too,
or could we just watch the video?
So there's Orlando Bloom.
He shared it on his Instagram.
But look at him-
Shot there above,
then there's the shark right there.
Maybe like three, four feet away
from him underneath them.
Stud.
So I will say in addition
to megawatt movie star charisma
that Orlando is bringing to this epic production,
the proximity of the shark is more impressive
than in the video that he made a view
where it was like 50, 60 meters away from you.
Was easier to get there on a stand-up paddle board,
and he knew exactly, like he was going
from, like, he had something to follow on the board,
whereas when I was swimming,
he didn't find it until I was in the water.
But point taken, Orlando's better on camera.
Right.
Yeah.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
While we're at it, we should probably also share,
we're gonna talk about this a little bit more later,
but I participated in the Malibu Triathlon
this past weekend.
Yes.
And there was another drone shot of the elites,
the pros in the Super League Triathlon Series who competed
this past Saturday,
there's a drone shot of the swim group from above
and there's a shark pretty nearby.
Yeah.
And that kind of spread among the triathlon community
pretty rapidly over the weekend.
So Blake, pull that one up.
I just saw it there a second ago.
There you go.
You can play that.
So you can see the big group of swimmers,
and there's the sharks, maybe 20 meters.
Yeah, he's waiting for the end.
He wants to get the stragglers.
Oh, he's coming closer.
Oh no, this is zooming up there.
So there's a yellow circle around the shark.
Yeah, that's good enough.
So-
Another one of my regular swimming areas.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
This is on Zuma Beach.
Not exactly like considered to be some kind
of reef where sharks congregate.
And this was the topic of much conversation
amongst all the athletes and participants over the course
of the weekend, talking about this,
many of them who were swimming for the first time
in a triathlon, or didn't have a lot of ocean experience,
and they're like, I hear there's sharks,
there are sharks out.
And I had to remind them the refrain that you explained
to me, which was this idea,
which is fundamentally kind
of behind the Malibu Artist's premise,
which is the sharks are always there.
Yeah.
They're all around you.
They actually really don't want anything to do with you.
For the most part, they're minding their own business.
It's a nice reminder that it's their terrain, their home,
not ours, but for the most part,
you can be afraid seeing that,
but you can also equally choose to see it
as somewhat safer,
given that they're seemingly disinterested in humans
for the most part, and-
Interested, like vaguely interested, that one.
He was sniffing around the edges,
(Adam laughs)
but you didn't bother anyone.
No, he didn't bother anyone.
That area actually, Zuma,
it runs toward between Trancas and all the way
to Paradise Cove is a Marine protected area
where we swim off and is around Point Dume
a little bit further,
I guess it's south East.
South East.
South East, yeah, yeah.
And we have seen dolphins with a bite out of them.
We have seen sea lions, decapitated beach.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
We've seen, there is, even Carlos would say,
he knows the sharks that do come around there actually tend
to be bigger than the ones where I am swimming
in the Palisades.
So no, it is a shark area, they ping off those buoys.
The whole area is a shark area.
Like I've said before,
if there's a good test to find out if there's sharks
in the water, you stick your finger in the water
and you lick it, and if it's salty, there are sharks.
Mm-hmm.
Is that too much?
Is that.
I think we just found the standout quote
for the whole podcast.
Yeah.
Put that on the thing.
Right.
The title.
If water is salty, it's shark-infested.
(Adam laughs)
I didn't say it's infested.
No.
Anyway, also doing well, props to April.
My wife, April Wong is training for a half marathon.
Nice.
We'll get into the half marathon stuff a little bit later,
but her training is rocking.
She ran 10 miles yesterday.
She's also on nuMe, by the way.
For the first time, she's like, she wants
to get any semblance of the baby body out
of her life, and she's lost seven pounds
in less than two weeks on nuMe,
which is kind of a psychological,
like psychology-based platform with kind of mindful eating
and good eating habits
and with a psychological background.
I don't know if you've ever heard of it,
but I'd never heard of it.
I hadn't, no-
My sister lost 20 pounds on it,
and then April decided to take it.
We were just having my sisters and April decided
to take a look at it.
And so she's doing that kinda concurrently
and it's going really well, so props to her.
That was really cool.
That's cool.
Yeah.
And did we recap your Alcatraz swim last time?
I can't remember.
I don't think so, 'cause it was before.
Right, that's right because we taped early,
then you were gone, so we haven't gotten the full breakdown.
So I'll give-
This is gonna be a whole race report-oriented podcast,
I think, right?
Yeah, there's a lot
of race report.
I'll give you my basic race,
but I was hoping, I was, to be quite honest with you,
slightly annoyed with my performance
'cause I'd been getting better
and a little bit faster for me,
and I had my goal of, I thought for sure,
I'd break an hour, and I wanted to break 50 minutes.
Mm-hmm.
It's a 1.27 mile swim.
I ended up covering 1.6 miles.
(Adam laughs)
Yeah.
Which hurt my hurt my time,
and then I still think I had the hour within my grasp
until you see my finishing kick.
Blake, can you zoom in on mine?
Yeah, so we're pulling up Blake's-
Incredible.
Look at my log, look at that beautiful line.
And then look at that, once you're in Aquatic Cove Park,
you're basically there.
It's still water.
You're done.
Why are you going up and down and backwards.
You might ask I'm going backwards at that moment.
Yeah.
I am asking you that actually, do you have an answer?
(Adam laughs)
I had no idea.
So for sure, there is one reason.
There were sailboats in the Cove,
which I wasn't, I didn't know,
and so I had to go around like three different sailboats,
but that certainly doesn't mean you should go backwards.
There should be a forward way.
There a couple of reasons why it was difficult for me.
First more difficult was it was actually a warm day.
It was 64 degrees,
so it was perfectly comfortable, I was in no wetsuit.
That's warmer than the Pacific this past weekend.
Yeah, yeah, definitely.
And it was, there was a chop,
there was a crosscurrent
that made it a little more challenging,
and then sighting is more challenging.
I'm used to swimming along the coast.
So crossing even a small channel like that.
Do they have buoys up?
They had kayakers.
And so we were, like, I was with my buddy, John Moore,
who I swim with out here and he and I both said,
let's go out 'cause Antonio told us,
"Go a little bit further to the right,
"and then you'll catch the current."
Towards the bridge.
Toward, yeah, "Go a little bit towards the bridge
"and then catch the current."
And we thought we had,
we went a little too far out.
And then we caught the current, and which was good,
but by the time we got to Aquatic Park,
I thought I was, I just kept going the wrong way.
Many times I thought the finish line was on the far side,
it turned out is on the near side, and I screwed it up.
So the bottom line is I've done a 5K swim,
I've done Alcatraz and I've done a four-mile swim once
in The Bahamas ages ago.
And each time I came near the end,
never the last, but very close to last,
this time at least I was in the middle of the pack.
Aha.
So like there is that, I did better.
That's huge.
Yeah.
But also I didn't meet my goal time
and I am slightly annoyed,
which means I have to do Alcatraz again.
Right.
But if you zoom out and you can see this arc
in your trajectory, that's typical.
And I think that that was wise advice to tack to your right,
because we talked about this before, like the longer,
you start in between the ebb and the slack, right?
Like so there's this kind of dead zone
that is very temporary,
but quickly the tide is gonna start coming in
and you know that you're gonna get pushed to your left.
So it is wise to tack to your right.
The idea is that in that tacking, then as the tide picks up,
you're gonna get pushed to your left,
and ultimately what you're gonna see is a straight line,
not quite as arc does that, but.
It's not even really arcs.
It's more jagged.
Like if you really zoom.
We have that.
In the middle there, there's something weird going on.
We suddenly you started swimming out
towards the Golden Gate Bridge for some reason.
No, no, Rich, that's art.
That's art.
Yeah, that's Strava art.
It's Strava art, I was trying (laughs) to.
You should've spelled Zuma out there.
That's a cry for help is what that is.
But nice job.
You did it without a wetsuit.
Thanks, man.
I would have liked to have seen
the starting position a little bit closer to.
It's a permit situation.
The boat was close to Alcatraz.
I don't know if that's maybe where the GPS picked it up.
You know how that happened?
I don't know if that ever happens with you.
My watch, definitely it happens.
You are in the shadow of the island,
but you can't start on the island
for whatever reason.
Right.
So you did it in one hour and two minutes.
Yeah.
You have a 213 per 100 yard pace.
It's in the record books.
I did, I swam too long.
How is that like, is that amount
of, is that normal to swim 1.6 for a 1.3, do you think?
And like do you think you swim close?
Well, let's pull up my Strava from the Malibu Triathlon,
which was yesterday.
Zoom in on that.
Obviously there's a shorter, is a quick little swim.
What I see is a very straight line, Adam.
(Adam laughs)
Now, I can see that there are differences in current.
I had buoys, I had all kinds of things,
but what you don't see are a lot of jagged lines
and boat out or anything like that.
We also see a 109 per 100 yard pace.
Yes.
Now, I will couch that with a caveat
that there was a little bit of running.
I had to run into the water and then I had a jog out
up onto the sand and then to the transition area.
And you had a sweatsuit.
Which, yeah, I was wearing a wetsuit,
yes, which obviously lowers the pace.
That's me coming out.
See all those people around there?
They all have, see how they all have different colored caps?
Yeah.
That's because they were from earlier heats,
so don't be confused.
Oh!
Those people did not start with me.
They started many minutes ahead.
So I'm gonna blow my own horn a little bit.
They finished behind you.
There a nice little like surf behind you.
There was some surface there.
It was pretty chill out there.
There was just a beach break at the end.
It was actually very calm.
It was, the conditions were great.
The water was fine.
I didn't see any sharks,
although I was comforted in knowing
they were all around me the whole time.
We'll get into more about the Malibu Triathlon
in a minute, but-
Bit that's over a half.
It was supposed to be a half-mile swim and you swam
a couple hundred yards too long as well.
Well, yeah, it's true, it says 1,200.
I thought maybe the swim longer
'cause it was supposed to be,
I thought it was like a 700-meter swim, which, well,
with the running part, it got added to it
'cause I didn't turn the garment off
until I was in the transition zone.
So there was a good, I don't know,
more than a quarter mile of running.
That's a hell of a pace, dude.
I don't wanna spoil it, you tell the story,
but you really kicked ass.
Well, look, we had fun.
So here's how it came about.
Alexi Pappas, podcast-favorite, contacted me.
She said that she'd been contacted by the Malibu Triathlon
and invited to do the celebrity race as a relay.
She wanted to know if I would do it with her,
which of course that sounds like fun,
and she got her bestie,
Mary Cain involved, also friend of the pod.
So this is a pod-tastic relay team
that we put together.
Mary, Mary a runner?
Mary, for those that don't know,
was the greatest runner of her generation as a young person.
Her career didn't really pan out as she would've liked.
She had experiences training under Alberto Salazar,
the Nike Oregon Project
that kind of derailed expectations
around her becoming this great Olympic champion.
She has now emerged from that phase of her life
and started this running team
called Atalanta in New York City,
that's all about women empowerment, athlete empowerment.
And she's been spending time on the bike.
So she doesn't have any experience racing bikes
or doing triathlons, but she was doing the bike leg,
Alexi the run leg, and I agreed to do this one leg,
and I thought, this is gonna be great,
first of all, crazy that we would be invited to do
the celebrity division of this race
'cause it's like, are they hard up
for like, like traditionally over the years,
like the Malibu Triathlon is like an institution in Malibu
and it's this celebration,
not only of multi-sport but of our community,
and it's really the only multi-sport race that I'm aware of
where there's this intersection
between the entertainment industry, like Hollywood,
with something athletic.
And over the years it's been graced
by many an A-list movie star, like J-Lo did it.
I remember when she did it.
Matthew McConaughey has done it.
Like a lot of people that you know
from movies and television participate in this,
they raised tons of money for children's hospital,
I believe, and various charities over the years.
So I thought this will be hilarious, let's do it.
We're actually all athletes.
I wouldn't consider us celebrities in the traditional sense,
but we should just destroy this
because like we're gonna be competing against people
on reality TV shows and like sitcom actors and people
on CBS shows or something, like this is gonna be great.
You're gonna compete against.
And the guys from "Suits,"
(Adam and Rich laughing)
and stuff like that, right?
'Cause that's the way it's always been.
Right.
And what was really fun and fantastic and surprising
and amazing and also like tricky about the whole thing
is we show up and it turns out
that there are a couple people that you know
from, like Chace Crawford,
like people who are in movies and television,
there was like five or six of those types of people.
But for the most part,
all the relay teams in the celebrity division were stacked
with professional triathletes and Olympians.
Like basically, all of the people who medalled (laughs)
in the Tokyo Olympics in triathlon,
were all like on various relay teams.
So way more often than not,
like these teams were propagated by legit,
like elite athletes in their prime triathletes
in their prime, and not reality TV stars.
And part of that is because, just for some context,
an organization called Super League Triathlon,
which is this new race series in triathlon that's oriented
around like really good prize money for the triathletes
as well as trying to get audience excitement
around triathlon because they reimagined the format
to make it much more washable and exciting for the viewer.
And it's a big deal in Europe.
They do all these races as part of a circuit.
They accumulate points.
Well, Super League Triathlon,
the organization, purchased the Malibu Triathlon,
so they now own it,
and this was the first North American instance
of Super League Triathlon
being conducted in this part of the world.
So on Saturday, that was the, all the pros raced,
and you have like the Olympic champion, Christian Blue,
you had Lucy Charles-Barclay,
who just won the 70.3 World Championships
a couple of weeks ago,
like all of these super elite young people.
And then they just took all of those incredible athletes
and said, we'll put you guys on relays
in the celebrity division.
So a lot of them had like two Olympians or like-
Crazy.
And then they'll have one person who's kind
of like the Achilles Heel,
like Hollywood person or whatever.
So that changed the sort of complexion (laughs)
of this whole thing,
because we're going and going and thinking,
we're gonna destroy this thing.
Like there's nobody who's gonna come anywhere near to us.
And that was a big catalyst for getting me back
into the pool
and like training with some intentionality around it.
So not that I'm in any kind
of race fit situation right now,
but at least I've been mixing it up in the pool
and felt comfortable kind of getting after it.
So we show up at the transition area in the morning,
and it's like, we're backing our bike right next
to Lucy Charles Barkley, ad then there's Christian Blue.
No relation, no relation?
Yeah, no relation to the Charles Barkley from the NBA.
Yeah.
But like a superstar in triathlon.
And I had met Christian Blue a couple nights prior
at an event.
And then there he is,
and he had another Tokyo Olympian doing the swim
on his relay, like, and he was the transition area felt
like being in the transition area
of like the elite performers in all of the sport.
(Rich laughs)
That's crazy.
Which was great.
So I line up for the swim,
I'm doing the swim leg, and I'm looking around
and I'm not seeing a lot of like elite-type people.
So I thought, mm-hmm, maybe I got this thing sorted out.
Like I think I'm in good shape, and they're counting down.
They're like the two-minute warning, the one-minute warning.
And then with like 30 seconds to go before the gun
was gonna go off for our heat,
like five or six athletes suddenly like run up
from the water and like join our group.
Like the real triathletes I've been in the water
warming up, and they shoved the last minute.
And I was like, oh, nevermind.
Were you in the front?
Did you like know?
Yeah, I was like, yeah, I'm like looking, where's my line.
Like where do I line up?
And like, yeah, I'm very like, I'm all about that.
So my aspirations for like winning
my heat of the swim went out the window.
So we run in-
Did you get wet first at all?
You're dry?
Yeah. It was, I should've.
I should've actually.
Does that help getting a little bit first?
Yeah, of course, you should warm up.
I don't know why I didn't.
That was dumb.
But anyway, we run into the water,
and to the first buoy, I was right up,
I was in, I was sort of on the heels.
I was in the lead pack,
but kind of in the back part of the lead pack
of like five or six people.
And we round the first buoy and had alongside the shore
and I lost touch with that group,
I fell off the back, and I thought, oh man,
like I thought I was like a better swimmer than maybe I am,
like, I need to like reevaluate.
Reevaluating your life.
Yeah, I'm like, I need to rethink
like, 'cause I was like,
I'm a pretty good swimmer, like of people my age,
there aren't very many people my age
that can swim as well.
And, so I thought, I could be competitive with any
of these people.
And when I fell off the back of that group,
I literally was like, yeah, I was examining my life.
I thought, you know what?
You've really indulged your ego here.
Like, you're really not all that, dude.
Like you need to really recalibrate and you need
a lot more training and like I'm running this whole thing
in my head the whole time.
You're like, how dare you, Rich?
How dare you?
And then I get out,
we run up the shore and the thing is like,
there's a bunch of like,
we were the fourth wave or something like that.
So you start catching up to the waves
before the slower people in the waves before you,
and then it becomes like this obstacle course
of just like swimming around all of these people,
run up on shore,
have a much longer run to the transition
than I would've preferred.
That was actually the hardest part of the whole thing.
Is that why you were tumbled over-
I was tired.
The run was really the thing that like blew me out, I had-
Because when you get out of the water
and, is grueling.
That, but then you run up and then you're on pavement.
They have like this carpet on this pavement to take it.
And the transition area
for like the, quote, unquote, celebrity division
was all the way at the NCA
to run through the entire transition area
for all of the participants to get to the very, very end.
So, yeah, I was definitely fatigued,
and I was beating myself up, oh God,
I thought I was gonna be better.
I was gonna be out with the lead group.
And they were like, no, you were fine.
Everybody who beat you was a professional.
Certainly I felt better.
(Rich and Adam laughing)
But you-
No nonprofessional triathlete beat me out of the water,
so that was my, like, that's the thing
I'm gonna hang my hand on.
But you also said you were in a group of five
and you fell off the bat.
I think I came out fourth.
Yeah, you came out fourth.
And then I looked at the results.
Apparently, so the organization sends you the results.
The funny thing is I get this email and they're like,
"Here's your results.
"We don't publish the celebrity division results."
Oh, that was interesting.
Why not?
Yeah-
'Cause like don't want that on the internet.
Like if some TV person doesn't want anyone to know
like how long it took them to run
the thing or whatever.
But anyway, so yeah, I was like, I think
I was 13, something, 1315,
the fastest was 1125, and then there were a couple of 12.
So I was a minute and a half or whatever off the back
of people who do this for a living
who are in their twenties.
So then I felt a lot better about myself.
Then-
Good job.
Alexi gets on, or Mary gets on the bike.
She does phenomenal.
Like she doesn't even have a proper cycling kit.
This is how new she is to, and she got a flat,
like before the thing even started.
Who fixed it?
And she thought her break was, yeah,
like when I'm swimming, she's like, "I have a flat."
She got Christian to help her fix her bike.
She got the guy who won the gold medal (laughs)
in the Olympics Triathlon
to help get her bike sorted out in time.
You're in the right team.
Yeah, that's when you know
you're on the right team.
Yeah, which is amazing.
(Adam laughs)
So Mary goes off, she has a great ride,
for somebody who has no experience.
And Alexi, of course, is like the team captain
and the cheerleader and she's mugging
for the, Alexa is just.
I wish they could both be here today to share.
Mary had to fly back to New York.
Maybe we'll get Alexi in here for a future "Coach's Corner,"
we'll talk more about what went out, what went down.
She was phenomenal and-
Has she run?
She do like-
She great.
Like sub-six minute mile.
She's such a champ.
I don't know what her pace was, but it was fast.
Like, it's not a joke.
Like she's for real.
Yeah, yeah.
(Rich and Adam laughing)
I was thinking it had to be in the fives, right.
Per mile, don't you think?
I would have to look.
I would have to pull it up.
I wouldn't be surprised.
Yeah.
But we held our place.
So I think we, yeah, we ended up fourth,
which considering that we were racing against teams
that had two, we were the fastest team
that had less than two Olympians on it.
Mm-hmm.
(Rich laughing)
Less than two.
So we didn't win,
but I feel really good about how we did.
Most importantly, we had a really fun time,
and it was cool to mix it up with those Olympians
and joke around with them and stuff like that.
So super fun.
Shout out to my boy, Dylan Efron, who did,
he was in the celebrity division,
but he didn't do it as a relay,
he did it, the whole thing himself,
and he took the W
for the Men's Individual.
Really?
He's an incredible athlete.
Is he related to Zac Efron?
Yeah, he's Zac's brother.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Incredible athlete, and showed up and rocked it out.
Rocked it.
Yeah.
Cool, I would like to shout out Julie,
who's a swimmer that swims with us at Point Dume a lot,
and she swam collegiately at Cal State Northridge.
She had a team with her niece, Raven,
and Raven was on the bike, a bike
she had just bought like 10 days,
but she's a great athlete too.
She played tennis in college at LMU, and Julie swam,
like I said, and Julie was fourth out of the water
on the Saturday race.
Mm-hmm.
And they finished 11th overall.
That's great.
And yeah, so they did amazing,
and so shout out to them.
What a great event?
You know what?
I would have loved to have been part of it,
maybe I'll orient my life next year towards trying to-
You should, at a minimum,
being the swimmer on a relay would be fun.
No, one's really asking me to do that.
No.
Well, we have a whole year to campaign for that.
I will say this, lots of podcast fans out there
this weekend, so thank you to everybody who came up
and said, hello, took lots of selfies with people.
And there was a lot of collegiates there.
So a lot of colleges sent their triathlon team.
So there were packs of like young people,
like the Air Force Academy
and this university, that university.
Cal had a huge team there,
and it was really fun to talk to all the college kids
and to see, especially the collegiate women, younger,
the girls, young women,
responding to Alexi and Mary,
'cause they're just like icons to young female athletes
and it was really cool to see that interaction,
and just to celebrate multi-sport and do it
in a really supportive environment and celebrate Malibu
and the oceans and the sharks-
You guys seem like you had a great time.
So, yeah.
It was really fun.
It comes across in all the videos.
Really fun.
Yeah.
And how's the overall kind
of, you said this was the impetus
to take swimming more seriously,
but you've been in the pool and the gym,
how's that all going?
How's your-
It's good.
I feel like I'm at the very beginning of it.
My body's gotten a lot bulkier from being in the gym
and swimming a lot.
I'm more top-heavy than I'm used to feeling,
and that's like weird.
Sometimes I like it sometimes I don't, but I am enjoying
focusing on swimming.
It is my strength and it's the one thing
that I haven't like ever really fully indulged
as a later-stage athlete (laughs)
like I've done all these triathlons,
but I've never really focused
on like, what if I doubled down on the thing
that I'm best at and see where that can take me?
And I'm kind of interested in exploring that right now.
So it's been, for channel crossings or-
More like, yeah, like open-water distance swimming.
Let's see what's in store there.
And it was really all catalyzed by this back injury
that has forced me to take a little bit
of a break from running.
So it's that idea of making lemonade out of lemons
a little bit, or identifying the opportunity in the setback
and just saying, okay, well, this is where I'm at,
here's what I can do while I'm trying to sort out
my back issues,
which I'm actively working on, working
with this wonderful woman named Monica Leslie,
who actually, she was introduced to me by Alexi,
and she came down for the race as well.
She's really been helping me out with a whole variety
of exercises and I've been in the gym
and just approaching it with intentionality.
So, yeah, we'll see.
We'll see.
But it was fun to, Catalina what?
Are we doing the Catalina swim?
Yeah.
I don't know if Hank Wise has anything to say about it.
Hank Wise called us.
I'll play you the message.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You should hear it,
yeah, I'd like to hear that.
(Adam laughs)
Hank is the best.
Yeah, yeah.
I wanna meet him.
Yeah, he's great.
So for those that don't know,
Hank was a teammate of mine at Stanford
who's now a, not only
a very accomplished open-water swimmer,
but also a coach that's down in the Long Beach Area,
and just a character, yeah, his character.
And he does all kinds of like recipe videos on Instagram.
(Adam laughs)
This dolphin boy on Instagram,
and he makes like vegan salads and stuff like that.
He's just, he's so charismatic and entertaining.
Yeah, and he has the record
for the fastest Catalina crossings.
Oh, he does?
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, the reason I brought up Catalina
is 'cause that's the Jim McConico tale
as he was Jim McConico was a storied USC swimmer.
He's from Ventura,
and he's a life guard now on the beach here in Malibu,
but he lived in Ventura.
He wasn't a lifeguard yet.
He was just working.
His family had car dealerships
and he's working in a family business and making money,
and I guess he turned 50.
He stopped, he was something like an eighth
or maybe a hundredth of a second or two hundredths
of a second off of making the Olympic team in 1972
or something didn't happen,
gave up swimming, ended up working fifth, in 19,
by the time he turned 50,
he's kind of overweight and see,
he's watching stuff on the couch,
he's like, what am I doing with my life?
And he decides, you know what?
I'm gonna get back in the pool.
And he ends up setting every record
for all these channel islands.
At one point he held every single one, including Catalina.
I think he's got the record for being the oldest
for time and age and several of them still.
Wow.
And he's, I think he's 70, in his seventies now.
I did a story on him in a relay he did
from Saint Nicholas Island,
which is behind Catalina, for The New York Times
and kinda swam with the Ventura Deep Enders.
He has a master's group called the Deep Enders.
They're the deep of the pool,
but they also do a lot of open-water swimming in Ventura.
And he started, like I said, if you're he doubled down
on his strength like that,
like who knows what you could do, really?
Wow!
That's cool.
That's inspiring.
Yeah.
And you got it, Jim's great, a great guy.
I think this is your path.
My path?
Yeah.
(Adam laughing)
You got the Alcatraz Women, you got a little taste of it.
I did.
I would, my path,
I liked, what I like about swimrun and swimming
is I like this idea of through courses.
Like what I wanna do to train before I get into Catalina
is I wanna do from Sunset Point to the Venice Skate Park,
just do a swimrun.
I have this idea of like swim-running,
but Big Sur Coastline or swimming the Nepali Coastline.
That's the kinda stuff I'm interested in.
The full-channel swim,
you have to hire a boat and you have to do,
like that just doesn't interest me right now.
Rules.
You're an experiential athlete.
I wear a mask, bro.
Yeah.
I wear a mask.
You do.
(Rich laughing)
I swim wear master tolerated.
(Rich and Adam laughing)
I don't know how tolerant they would have been.
The Malibu Triathlon Community highly tolerant?
Yeah.
I think your mask might've tested that tolerance.
(Adam laughing)
You should never know until you try.
Yeah, I would have been, it would have been funny to see.
All right.
So what else?
We're both going up to the Surf Ranch this week.
That's right.
Explain what the Surf Ranch is.
The Surf Ranch, a brain child of Kelly Slater,
I don't know if he's still associated with it or not,
but he wanted to basically create
a way to ride the perfect waves in the middle
of the, inland somewhere.
Mm-hmm.
And so to launch this, this was the first one, I think,
that they built.
There's multiple now.
Yeah.
There's one in Waco, Texas.
Right.
I know.
Is that still part of this same thing-
I don't think they're owned by the same organization.
So I think there's a foil that kind of runs on a track
that builds this wave and there's different levels
and depends on which part of, I guess, the pool
that you're in.
I've never been to it before,
but Red Bull is having a day at the Surf Ranch,
apparently sponsors that work with WSL,
'cause WSL owns it now, are able to like part of the package
when they sponsor a competition or whatever, it all says,
is they get a day at the Surf Ranch.
So at this day, Kai Lenny and Jamie O'Brien
are gonna be there, Zion Wright,
the skateboarder is gonna be there.
I'm gonna go up and talk to both those surfers,
New York Times Sports, and I'm talking to them
about a couple of features on both those guys.
So we will see what happens,
but that's my kind of impetus for me going.
I'm a little terrified of surfing in front of them.
Yeah, I know, right?
(Adam laughing)
But surfing in front of them.
I'm not a surfer.
Indulge in your vulnerability, Adam.
It's an opportunity for performative vulnerability.
When was the last time-
I feel the same way.
Like I've been asked before,
and I couldn't make the schedule work,
but if I was being really honest,
there was a little intimidation.
It's like, I'm gonna go up here.
Like I've served,
but I wouldn't consider myself a surfer,
and I haven't-
When was the last time
you stood up on a wave?
Seven years maybe.
Like I just, I don't do it.
I don't do it.
I've gone through periods where I've done it,
and then I can get somewhat proficient so I can kind
of stand up and ride a wave, but it's been so long.
Like, so it's like the idea of going there
and like all these pro surfers are there.
Yeah.
(Rich laughing)
Yeah, you're gonna go,
but they do, in the information that they sent us,
they have like beginner baby waves and stuff like that.
So I think we're just gonna have to get over ourselves.
Dude, I'm gonna give it a shot.
It's been over 10 years since I stood up on a wave,
but being a guy who's written about surfing
for the New York Times, it makes me even doubly,
like I feel like I'm gonna be unmasked.
You are gonna be unmasked.
The mask is really this, you're hiding behind it.
Who are you, Adam?
What are you hiding behind that snorkel mask?
Who is anybody, Rich?
Right now-
That's a deflection.
Right now, I'm the guy that's relistening
to the "David Show Podcast" that you just did.
That's how much I liked it.
And also kind of like recognizing (laughs)
some internal character flaws that I carry,
but we'll have a good time.
I'm so glad you're gonna come.
That's-
Yeah, it's gonna be fine.
Yeah.
I can't wait.
A couple running-related things
I wanna mention quickly before we pivot,
one is our boy Davy Greenberg
just did his first half marathon last weekend.
This is a guy who, Davy, like you have never done
any races before, right?
Like never had been a runner, you hadn't,
did you play sports in high school?
Not well.
No (laughs) not well, has discovered he's running-
He's the artist that needs
to become a runner.
Really, the catalyst here
to give full credit is, like, I think really inspired you.
Right?
To get after it,
and you've like taken that mantle and you got serious
about training for the L.A. Marathon,
come on over here, Davy,
and Davy just ran his first race
this past weekend half marathon.
Yeah.
And I gotta say, man, I'm super proud of you.
It's impressive.
So we pulled up your Strava, let's look at the stats here.
So pace, what was your average pace?
711.
711 pace in your very first half marathon.
Started out 828.
And the original plan was to take my time
and just finish, but then I got competitive.
So we got, yeah, you started off
with 828, 710, 706, 656, 659,
707, 704, 647, 650, 658,
703, 716, 640, 627.
Impressive and incredibly consistent.
And there's some hills in there too, right?
Between mile two and three,
I think it's called the California Climb.
It was a lot.
Dude!
Yeah.
It was fun.
I'm seeing a whole new thing for you, man.
What's great is been you've been sharing this
on social media on Davy Runs and the enthusiasm and the kind
of community that you've surrounded yourself with
and like invested in with the Koreatown runners
and et cetera, like you look like you're having a lot of fun
and it's almost like this light has gone off inside of you.
It is one of the most fun things I've ever done, and yeah,
figuring that out in my mid thirties has been really cool.
That's cool, man.
Like you, I remember after I started kind of doing
the podcast with you guys, you did like a four-mile run.
You did some run that was like the first run
you had done and maybe ages or something,
that was like a year ago, right?
Yeah.
I started like during the pandemic, basically.
And then you stop for a minute.
Yeah.
And then I got burnt out.
And then Hellah came in.
And then Hellah came in,
and Solema doing his, after he was on the show,
did one mile a day for 30 days, then I decided to do,
and then Hellah on the show, and then I just, yeah.
You've been doing it ever since.
Now I'm rocking, yeah.
How is the Koreatown Club.
So fun.
It's five times a week,
like a big crew of people, and it's really exciting.
That's great, yeah.
And L.A. Marathon is when?
November 7th.
Cool.
And then the big Sur Marathon.
Oh, I didn't know you signed up for another one, okay.
Got into the drawing, so yeah.
That's an easy, that one.
No.
(Davy and Adams laughing)
Yes, no, that's-
That's a different animal.
Yeah.
There's some good weather and some hills involved in that.
Good.
Yeah, yeah.
Awesome.
Well, we'll continue to share that experience,
and it's great, man.
I think Hellah has had a big impact on a lot of people,
like having Hellah on the show.
Jason, our, our producer and engineer started his run streak
after Hellah was on the show and has not missed a day.
I think he's like, is it in the 69, seventies?
Is in the seventies.
He's in the seventies.
He might be at a 80, I don't know.
And then we got Blake who ran, what did he do?
13 miles with like 2,500 feet of elevation at the weekend?
Blake is our video dude,
and we did, Davy Greenberg is our photographer.
So I love the trickle-down like kind of impact-
And to be honest, that's what the real world-
Real-world results in terms
of like impacting other people,
which I love, and it's great.
'Cause that's what the, should be.
It should be a bunch of people get-
I hope so, otherwise, what are we doing here?
(Adam and Rich laughing)
What does your podcast do, Rich?
Which we're gonna get into a little bit later.
But watching both those guys,
Davy and Blake in particular,
'cause I have I Davy on Instagram,
Blake on Strava, seeing it happen and you're right.
Blake, Blake's run was really inspiring
and seeing Davy's footage and the way he's so happy
and smiles, it inspires, it's really great.
It's the sheer joy and glee of it all,
I think that is the infectious part
of the way Davy's been sharing.
And I've seen those Koreatown run guys,
they did a run on the beach when I was swimming one morning
and it is like a 16-miler,
like start like the whole bike path or something.
And it's fun.
I could see in this day and age where like it's kind
of problematic to go out and party or to go to clubs
or to go to even to go to shows,
a lot of people are doing it,
but a lot of people probably are still afraid to do it,
to do something like this that is social.
It's probably a great thing.
Yeah.
And there's multiple clubs and organization,
there's the BESTIES, you go out with the BESTIES Crew,
is BESTIES is a vegan restaurant here in L.A.
and they've got a run crew
and you're gonna be spending more time downtown, right?
So there's the Blacklist Crew down there that I'm sure
you'll vibe with.
So it's gonna be cool.
And there's a, I've got a crew.
You do?
What's your crew?
April and Zuma.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
Zuma and April.
Yeah.
Zuma is upfront.
I'm usually pushing the baby sled.
Well, she's got the half marathon thing, so.
I'm the assistant.
I think you're missing the opportunity here.
To join her?
Yeah.
I'd like to, it's gonna depend on the weekend.
Like, so she, that one is, is it the Malibu Half Marathon?
Yeah, the Malibu Half Marathon.
So it's the week before.
It doesn't matter, I could still do it.
It's just gonna be a matter of, can we get someone
to watch Zuma, because he wouldn't wanna be pushed around
for 13 miles at my pace.
If Davy pushed him, he might be able to do it.
But at my pace, it wouldn't work, so-
That sounds like a solvable problem.
But there's actually, the solvable part
is that there is, you could do it virtually,
and April hasn't decided if she's gonna go to the race
or do it virtually, it's gonna depend on multiple factors.
So she's got to decide that, if it's virtual,
then I can certainly join her.
All right.
Yeah.
One more running thing I wanna mention is for those of you
that follow me on Instagram, you may know this already,
I have a partnership with Ten Thousand,
makers of the finest men's training gear on the planet.
I've hinted over the past several months
of a super secret project that I've been working
with them on over the course of the past year.
That project is coming to its fruition.
It is a new line of run gear for men that we're calling FAR,
which means Free Association Run.
Mm-hmm.
It's essentially a kit,
a shirt that comes in long sleeve and short sleeve
and shorts in two different color palettes that are made out
of recycled materials, tailored to my specifications,
and we've made some really cool kind
of next evolution in with respect to the running shorts
in terms of like a liner and how the phone pocket works
and all of that.
I'm gonna be sharing more about that
because this product line is gonna be coming out soon.
I'm so excited about it.
I've never worked with a company that's been so responsive
to feedback and so interested in trying to get it right,
like these guys, we went through a bazillion iterations.
They would send me sample after sample, after sample,
and what about this fabric?
And what about that fabric?
And we just went back and forth literally for a full year
to get this right.
And they were so committed to making sure
that it was correct and that it lived up to all
of our expectations and I'm really proud
of what we've created and I can't wait
until it's available for all you guys
and I can share a little bit more about it.
But we're in this kind of pre-order campaign phase
right now, so if you wanna be among the very first
to be able to order it or to learn more
when we break public with it,
the best way to do that is to text BTY
to the number 29071, or there's a link,
a URL that I will share in the show notes
or in the description below
if you're watching this on YouTube,
but excited about what Ten Thousand
is creating and excited
to have you guys experience it firsthand soon enough.
And when it comes out, we're gonna do the next Roll,
that Roll on in the outfit.
We will for sure be doing that.
And the gear.
Yes.
(Adam laughs)
We will be doing that for sure.
All right.
When we opened the show,
we talked about this show being biweekly.
This has become like a thing, right?
It started when I was confused
as to whether bi-weekly meant twice a week
or once every two weeks.
And then last week,
I did a deep dive into Merriam-Webster and realized
that it actually can be accurately defined
as either, like bimonthly is defined as something
that occurs every other month or every other week,
which is ludicrous.
So that means that this show, "Roll On,"
can be accurately defined as either biweekly or bimonthly,
which makes no sense.
None.
And somebody on social media forwarded me a video
on TikTok from this guy called Stage Door Johnny,
who does TikTok videos about problems
with English language,
like on semi-colons and punctuation and stuff like that,
and he did a whole riff on this very subject that I shared
on Instagram, and I said, "Adam, I feel seen."
(Adam laughing)
Like I do not feel alone anymore
in not understanding what is happening with our language.
So Blake, pull this up for those that are watching
on video, so let's play it from the beginning.
Maybe refresh the page and we play it
from the very beginning with the volume up.
So that's daily, weekly, monthly, yearly.
Don't forget hourly, something that happens once an hour.
Of course.
Now, a tricky one,
what about something that happens twice a week?
Biweekly?
Good one, the prefix bi donating two,
like bicycle binoculars.
What about twice a month?
Bimonthly?
Perfect.
Now, what about something that only happens once
every two weeks?
Biweekly.
No, that was for two times in one week,
and for something that happens only once every two weeks.
Actually, because most moms have four weeks in them,
doesn't bimonthly cover that too?
Twice a month, once every two weeks,
but some months have five weeks,
plus I want bimonthly to me once every two months as well.
So in a two-month period, if something is bimonthly,
it either happens once or four times.
Yeah.
(Rich and Adam laughing)
All right.
It's so good.
But we also had listeners from across the pond weigh in,
and they think it should be fortnightly.
Yeah, they were confused
as to why we wouldn't just be calling this fortnightly.
What they don't understand
is that here in America,
no one knows what the, I didn't know what fortnight meant.
Right.
That's what, and then-
Just like I don't know what a stone means.
Like in the comments, I forget,
was it YouTube or if it was on your Instagram,
but in the comments, it was kind of like, "Oh yeah,
"Americans don't use for it."
It was like a whole conversation amongst themselves,
but I think we should double down on fortnightly.
I think so.
Yeah.
Like Wimbledon-
Are we sure?
first of all, are we sure that that's what fortnight means?
Yeah, fortnight is two weeks.
I thought Fortnite was a video game.
No, I definitely don't feel seen.
Is that the same thing as Tech Mobile?
That's the last video game I played.
(Rich laughs)
All right, fortnight it is.
Words.
Words, Adam, we have one job.
The whole purpose of language
is to help us make sense of reality.
No, we purposely, we-
We collect the Royal we?
The collective we, and I mean writers,
we made it complicated, so you'd have to hire us.
Mm-hmm.
Right.
We don't want it to be easy, 'cause then you need-
You're the gatekeeper, right?
This is what like the whole legal profession is founded on,
like using a bunch of Latin phrases to create a barrier
so that you don't actually understand concepts
that actually aren't that difficult to understand.
It's weird.
It's like if the country had been founded by doctors,
would everything be just different?
Or if it had been founded
by like, it was founded by by lawyers.
Mm-hmm.
That's interesting?
Yeah.
But we have to create rules for society,
which is what the law is about.
We meeting you and your lawyer county.
We, the Royal we, the founding fathers, Royal we.
Writers couldn't found anything.
No founding coming from writers.
(Rich and Adam laughing)
All right.
We got a, towards the break here,
but I know that you wanted to quickly,
because in addition to your desire
to make this a swimrun podcast
that is supplanted only by your desire to make it
a free-diving-oriented podcast,
so I will indulge you with 60 seconds of free diving.
The "60 Minutes" and 60 seconds?
Yeah.
I just wanted to give props to Alexi Mulching
of the King of the Deep, according to "60 Minutes",
that's was I called him.
He was featured on "60 Minutes", excuse me.
(Adam clears throat)
And he was featured basically his record-breaking dive
in vertical blue for constant weight,
with a monofin where he broke his own world record.
That was featured on "60 Minutes".
And he was interviewed and he came off really, really well.
He's just a highly intelligent, really relaxed,
a great ambassador for the sport.
His goal is to eventually see it in the Olympics,
whether that happens or not, we will see,
but it does seem to be having a moment again,
the sport does.
They'd been on "60 Minutes" before, who's been
his chief rival over the course of his career
was featured eight years ago,
also in Dean's Blue Hole,
but not at the competition.
Bob Simon came out and did a thing on him.
This was a different reporter,
but I thought he came off really well,
and I just wanted to congratulate Alexi,
and we can just put the link in the show notes.
Yeah, that's cool.
What was the occasion for him being on "60 Minutes" now?
Like it's cool that free diving is getting this mainstream.
It happens every once in a while
where like people become interested
in this interesting subculture,
where people are putting on their own competitions
and doing incredible things and holding their breath
and going, he went 132 meters, I think was the record
he broke, 132, something like that,
and so that's 400 and it's like almost 500 feet.
And that's what he did on one breath.
It took him almost five minutes to do it.
So that alone is incredible.
Who knows what the impetus is?
He gets coverage every once in a while,
comes up and then that coverage often feeds other coverage.
I love it.
I like seeing these athletes get their due.
It is interesting to see it though,
like, 'cause I haven't had my finger on that pulse
for a while.
Lately I did a story on Alexi for The Times recently.
So that was kinda my first free diving story in a long time.
One thing I've noticed is the second tier, not the greatest,
but like the second-tier athletes are different
than when I was covering it more regularly,
like 2014, 2015.
In what way?
They're just different athletes because it's hard
to maintain this lifestyle.
You're paying-
Yeah, I thought you meant qualitatively.
Like just it's new people, 'cause they don't-
And new blood.
There's no longevity in this sport.
Exactly.
Because you have to pay for the everything.
Yeah.
So if you're not making your little living
and your lifestyle, it's hard to do it.
So, but the best are still the best.
And Alessia will will be going head-to-head
in the World Championships next week.
Alexi's at the World Championships.
I think Will's not gonna make it.
I believe his wife has given birth to their second,
so he won't be there.
So it kind of Alexi now,
it's almost like similar to Novak in tennis.
Like Alexi is kind of on his own now.
There's really not someone pushing him.
There's no one close to him from what I can see.
And the women has two great athletes like going head-to-head
exchanging records still.
So it's a great sport.
It's fun to tune into.
You can see even more than when I was covering it,
which is this company that does the underwater camera
on a track is at every major competition now,
there'll be at the World Championships.
So if you're interested in free diving,
look for the World Championships next week.
And now they're building these deep pools.
Yeah, so there's deep pools.
So Alexi (laughs) was at a deep pool
in Dubai and met-
Of course, Dubai's, is that where the deepest pool is?
Like.
There's one in Italy.
That was the first, I think.
And now there's the one in Dubai (clears throat) because one
of the leaders in Dubai, I forget who it is,
is really interested in free diving,
and he holds the biggest, in terms of money, competition.
And it's a static competition face down
in the water.
And that's like the biggest payday in free diving.
At least it was for when I was covering it.
I don't know if it's still active,
and he's behind this pool,
which includes little chambers and cool like fake wrecks.
And it's more theatrical than these other pools.
And he met, Alexi met Dan Bilzerian in Dubai,
who's apparently taken up free diving.
We met him at the pool, and Alexi has this desire
to, he wants to build the sport in the United States,
so it's like swimrun.
It's like even a lot of sports that do well overseas,
but haven't really reached their peak here,
and he wants to create more free divers
in the United States.
So you get Dan Bilzerian to do a free-
To build a pool maybe in Vegas.
That's Alexi's newest thing.
Aha.
I said, we'll see.
We'll keep you posted on that.
All right.
Well, we gotta close this down, but before we do that,
there was also a big spread about Alexi and GQ
where your book was quoted,
but they gave your attribution,
is that true?
Right, yeah, that's true.
So there was a big spread in GQ also, good story.
People shared it with me.
They pulled quotes that Natalia gave me
and quoted it without attribution.
So I did-
Welcome to the modern media ecosystem.
That's the way it is.
For years, people have been using some
of my Natalia quotes that I got
and printed in the book and New York Times,
Outside Magazine, and they'd been putting them
on Instagram tiles and after she died, that was done,
I feel felt that was nice.
It's homage to her.
I also, I think I'm the first to quote Wimbledon
or free diving is vertical blue,
that's used in marketing materials.
It's all fine.
But when a journalist does it, it's a little bit annoying.
So I emailed the guy and he apologized.
(Adam laughs)
Yeah.
But if it's digital, was it in print?
Could they just fix it?
It's print.
Mm-hmm.
But you know what?
Here's the deal.
I don't, the right, it happened in production.
According to what the writer said,
he had it in there and then they cut it out
because there's word counts.
I get it.
Fact Checker shouldn't put that writer in that position.
A fact checker is there to make sure
that if a writer's overlooking that or whatever,
you're working on behalf of the reporter,
the editor and the publication to make sure
that those things don't happen,
because I've had fact checkers
who would never let that slide.
They'd say, where'd you get that quote?
She's dead now.
Where'd you get that quote?
When was it done?
And they would just figure out a way to make sure
that should the attribution happens,
'cause that's what you're supposed to do.
You should've said,
he could've said,
told The New York Times or told X, Y, Z,
whatever it is, told Author Adam Skolnick or in the book,
one breath without my name, I don't need
to be name-checked,
but I think that writers should, people in the profession
should have a standard.
Thus concludes our 60-second segment on free diving.
It only took a few minutes.
It went longer than that, I think.
(Adam laughs)
Concluded with a treatise on journalistic ethics.
Thank you, Adam Skolnick.
We'll take a quick break,
and we'll be back with a very interesting conversation
with Lewis Pugh.
(air whooshing)
There he come.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome, but I wanna snack
a moment to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly, and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the Plantpower Meal Planner,
are affordable all-in-one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access to thousands
of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy-to-prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com, and right now,
for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RR Health at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff,
people, for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com, promo code, RR Health,
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right.
Let's get back to the show.
(air whooshing)
Okay, and we're back.
So we're gonna pivot to our brief conversation
with Arctic Swimmer, Lewis Pugh.
We've talked about Lewis quite a bit on the podcast,
so I don't wanna spend too much time introducing him,
but for those that are unfamiliar or new to this,
Lewis is an environmentalist.
He is somebody who has spent the last 30 years exploring
the world by swimming,
particularly swimming in very cold sections of the planet.
He just completed this swim in Greenland,
which was a world's first to draw attention
to the melting glaciers there,
and it's just the latest ice swim that he's done
to raise awareness for climate change.
What else do we need to know about-
He's a Hall of Fame marathon swimmer.
He's swam across the North Pole.
He's swam, he's the first to do that.
He's done the highest swim ever in a lake on Mount Everest.
The polar swim before this one was swimming
in a melting glacier in Antarctica,
literally going inside a glacier and swimming
in a glacial tunnel.
And just as always, swim cap, goggles and a swimsuit,
like a Speedo.
Right.
He's also a UN Patron of The Oceans.
On November 5th, on the fifth day of COP26,
he's gonna be giving the opening address
of the Youth and Oceans Day, which is interesting.
And he's really like an explorer
in the very traditional sense of the word, right?
Almost like out of a Wes Anderson movie,
like a guy who would be knighted
and spend his time in the explorers club
surrounded by wood paneling and all kinds of knickknacks
from the heyday of humans exploring the far corners
of the planet.
Like, and I say that in the most kind
of congratulate, like sort of positive light.
Yeah, he's, he's diplomat.
He's a diplomat.
He's a UN Patron od The Oceans, like you said,
and he is a professional diplomat
and he merges sports and diplomacy, but he also has
this burning red coal Greta Thunberg energy inside him too,
'cause he is on a mission to try to save us
from the climate crisis,
and he is as driven to do that
as you see any activists anywhere.
So that's what's so interesting.
Yeah.
Super intelligent and well-spoken on all of the issues.
So let's pivot to our conversation with him now.
(air whooshing)
Rich, I myself and Adam tried
to pull this thing off where Adam would come to Greenland.
Adam, I'm so sorry, we weren't able to pull it off,
but it's really an honor to be able to speak to both
of you today.
Thank you so much for giving me the time.
Well, we're delighted to have you.
We were, of course, disappointed
that Adam couldn't figure out with everything going on
in the world, how to get to Greenland,
but we followed your expedition very closely.
We're both big longtime fans.
I know that you have a preexisting relationship with Adam,
and we're just delighted in lieu of being able to do this
in person, to at least get you on a remote platform
to help share your work and your advocacy today.
So you're now safely ensconced in Cape town,
so thank you for joining us today.
I think the first thing we're curious about
is what drew you to Greenland this year?
Like why Greenland?
So walk us through how this expedition came together
and your thinking behind it.
Thank you so much.
I've been swimming now for 35 years,
and the last 18 of those have been in the polar regions,
and some always looking for a place where I can tell a story
about what is happening to these unique environments
and how it will impact us wherever you are in the world.
And I was drawn to Greenland
because it now has the fastest moving place in the world.
So the glacier is on the west coast of Greenland,
it's called Ilulissat.
Ilulissat the Intuit name for place of icebergs,
and it certainly is that,
but this place now is moving at a speed
of 40 meters per day in summer.
So I just thought this is a place
where I can share now,
before the big climate change negotiations start next month,
this is a place where I can share with the world
what is happening.
What is happening
is that there's this dramatic ice melt, right?
And we saw it in your swim where there were days
you couldn't swim because there was so much ice kind
of coming down the river and into the fjord,
and it was like you said, swimming across a motorway,
but filled with icebergs.
Is that correct?
Yes.
I want you to imagine you got the Greenland ice sheet,
which is the second biggest ice sheet in the world,
and on the edge, the ice sheet goes down valleys
and becomes glaciers, and at the edge of the glacier,
it is starting to carve and those carves into icebergs,
and then for a length
of about 60 kilometers down this long field,
you've got thousands and thousands
and thousands of icebergs.
And at the mouth of this field were a number
of really big ones, a kilometer tall, it's astonishing,
and they were grounded on the seabed.
And so I was trying to swim on the outside of these icebergs
across this field,
and then at 4:00 a.m. one morning,
I'll never, ever forget it,
I opened my curtains and I looked out and one
of these enormous icebergs was beginning to rotate.
So it was breaking up and it was rotating
and it opened up the flood gates
and literally we had 60 kilometers worth of icebergs,
thousands and thousands and thousands
going straight out to sea,
and within a few hours, they were 10 kilometers out to sea,
by the next day, they'd extended 50 kilometers to the north.
Wherever you looked out at sea, there were just icebergs.
There was no spare water anywhere, no clear water anywhere.
And so then having to, in a few days time,
there were some areas where I could do the swim, but again,
as soon as I got into the water,
it was like a motorway of ice.
And taking off my clothes,
we've got a clear routes to swim,
but within a short period of time,
now a big iceberg has moved in our way.
I've never seen a carving event like this in my life.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I think for most of us, intellectually,
we understand global warming and climate change
to be the existential threat of our time,
but it's purely an academic exercise for most of us.
We're now seeing warming events
and weather incidents
that are making it much more experiential,
but I think the power in your expedition
and what you've just experienced is it really puts
an exclamation point on the present reality
of what we're facing,
and my sense is that it was even worse
than what you expected,
in that you didn't realize there was gonna be this motorway
of smaller icebergs to have to navigate, and that in truth,
this scenario is far worse
than what we might've imagined and much more present.
And I think the narrative that comes out
of your adventure is really helping all of us
to embrace that reality in a more fungible, tangible way.
Yes, I agree with you.
So we've all seen the horrendous fires
which have been in California and in Turkey and in Greece
and in Siberia,
we seen them on television and some people
have witnessed them firsthand,
and we've all seen the dreadful floods
which occurred this year in Germany and in Belgium.
And we've heard about the melting of the ice,
but when you stand next to a field
and you watch as thousands and thousands
of icebergs literally are getting washed very quickly out
to sea, and then when you go up onto the ice sheet,
and everywhere you see
these what we call super glacier lakes,
so these are meltwater lakes on top of the ice sheet.
And what this does is that the water drills through the ice,
it finds cracks,
it goes all the way down to the bottom of the ice sheet,
to the bedrock,
making this ice sheet more and more unstable.
And this year, shortly before I started
the swim was a first time in recorded history
that scientists recorded rain
on the highest point in Greenland.
And so you put all these things together, all these events
which are happening all over the world and wildfires
down in Australia and the bleaching of the coral reefs,
you put them all together and it tells us a pattern
about what is happening,
and it shows us what will happen unless we get a grip
of the situation.
You, just one thing that people
might, if just for, just to make it really clear,
every summer, there is some melting of the ice sheet, right?
Just like the wildfires are not uncommon
or the king tide event we even saw here in Malibu,
which took half the beach away,
the beach where we are often in, where do a lot of swimming,
is now half the size of I've ever seen it before,
you were just there at Zuma.
And how do you, like for people who aren't as familiar,
how do you parse what's normal
and what's become augmented or extreme?
Or is that just not something that's even worth discussing?
Now, when you talk about the rain on Greenland,
that's one thing, it's never happened before,
but how do you explain to people what's happening
is just a bigger version of the natural cycle
and therefore it's dangerous?
Yes, so you're absolutely right.
From time immemorial,
glaciers have carved icebergs and icebergs have gone out
to sea, but it's the speed and the scale of the crisis,
of the climate crisis
which is taking scientists by surprise.
And just to give you a practical example,
so we've been talking about ice, which is on land.
Let me give you another example about ice
which is in the sea, so sea ice.
Back in 2005, I did a swim in the Norwegian part
of the Arctic, north of an island called Spitsbergen,
and there in summer, the water was three degrees centigrade.
I went back there 12 years later,
the water wasn't three degrees centigrade,
now it was 10 degrees centigrade.
Mm-hmm.
So going from three, 10 in just 12 years,
and the scientists are telling me that is not normal.
Mm-hmm.
That is an impact, simply warming the planet.
Luis, you mentioned that you've been doing these swims
for over three decades at this point.
I'm curious about the intersection
of your interest in environmentalism
with with your swimming,
like which came first?
And how do they inform each other?
Swimming came first.
So (laughs) I had my purpose, first proper swimming lesson
very late in life when I was 17.
I grew up in, initially in Britain,
but then I moved out to Cape town.
And for those of your listeners who've been to Cape town,
it's just an incredible place 'cause on the one side,
you've got the Indian Ocean, on the other side
you've got the Atlantic Ocean,
and my high school history class looked out
over the Atlantic ocean,
and in the distance, if I put my head out the window,
I could see Robin Island,
and I don't even know where the idea came from,
but I just wanted to swim to this island.
This was 1987.
This was a time when Nelson Mandela
and many people were imprisoned in South Africa.
Anyway, I got permission to do this swim,
and I barely made it.
And, but afterwards, every single year,
I've just tried to do another swim.
It really grabbed me.
I loved swimming so much.
And so every year I've done a bigger, harder, tougher
and inevitably colder swim.
And then there was a time in the early 2000s
where I began to notice how the oceans were really changing.
So whether it be the, what was happening in the Arctic
with the sea ice, we're just seeing less fish in the world,
with plastic all over our beaches,
and then there came a time when I realized I had to stand up
and talk about what I was seeing in the water oceans.
Mm-hmm.
And so tying the power of your swimming capabilities
to activism has become like your advocacy and your passion.
What is your sense of impact with all of this?
Like, are you encouraged by the results
of getting out there and doing things
that draw a lot of attention and interest
in what you're doing?
Like, how do we translate the inspiration
that we can garner from your epics swims
into real change?
It's really hard to measure the impact.
Somebody may look at my sermon and hopefully be inspired
to protect the environment in whichever area
that they operate in.
So it's very, very hard to measure it.
It's not like, let's say, selling shoes.
If you sell shoes, you know how many you sold at the end
of each month and the end of each year
and you know when you're being successful.
What I've concentrated on the last couple of years
is creating what we call Marine protected areas,
and Marine protected areas are like national parks,
but they're in the sea.
They prevents overfishing in these areas,
and the big success came a few years ago, 2016,
when I worked with John Kerry and a number of other people
to help create a very, very big Marine protected area
down in Antarctica.
So that Marine protected area is the size of Britain,
France, Germany, Italy, all put together.
It's the biggest protected area in the world,
but, and would've thought I'd be really happy about this,
but I'm not.
We're now in a race against time.
We're trying to create
another three big Marine protected areas around Antarctica,
and we're also working to try and get 30%
of the world's oceans now protected by 2030.
I think really interesting,
some of the stuff that you've done,
including like, I guess the last one before this,
you were actually swimming in a melting glacier.
Like you found a riverine glacial melt in Antarctica,
and you actually got inside a glacier and swam, I guess,
a kilometer inside this glacial river.
And that was an incredible moment as well.
And so you've found these really interesting places to go,
but something that people might not know of
is your partnership with Slava Fetisov,
the hockey star in Russia,
and I wanted to bring that up
just because, especially in America, we have this crazy kind
of black and white Russia versus the United States thing
that's been going on my entire life,
but really there's some really great environmentalists
on both sides.
Can you explain your partnership with him
and how he was involved in Antarctica, and just in general,
how he's an ally in climate?
Yeah.
So Slava is a very special person,
and for your listeners who don't know him,
he used to be the Captain
of the former Soviet Ice Hockey Team,
and then he was the first Russian to come over
and play professional ice hockey
in the United States of America.
The way I got to meet him was I was trying
to get this area done in Antarctica protected
called the Ross Sea, and under international law,
25 countries had to agree at, and one of those was Russia,
another of those was China,
and all the countries agreed except Russia and China.
And no matter how many times, it took 17 years,
diplomats were going backwards and forwards trying
to get these last two countries to agree it,
and they weren't able to agree it.
It was President Obama's last term,
and Obama was very passionate
about creating Marine protected areas,
he sent John Kerry through to Beijing,
and John was able to get the Chinese to agree it.
For the last hurdle, was obviously the Russians,
and I just, it sounds crazy,
I had this belief that if I could just go down there and do
a swim in this place and show the beauty of it and show
how magnificent it is and film the humpback whales and film
the emperor penguins
and all these other magnificent animals, this is their home,
we need to protect it.
This place was on the edge of being seriously overfished.
If I could do that and I could go to Russia and meet
with Russia's leadership,
I hope that I could persuade them that we must protect
this last great wilderness,
but I'm half British and half south African,
I had no friends in Russia,
but somebody introduced me to Slava Fetisov.
And I'll never forget what he said.
He said, "You know, Lewis,
"I'm a defense man,
"and the world needs more defenders and protectors.
"Do your swim, come here and I'll introduce you
"to who you need to meet."
So I went down there, I did the swim.
I then immediately got on a plane and I flew
from Cape town through to Moscow,
just not knowing what to expect,
and I arrived there, and there was Slava.
Slava Fetisov in Russia is the biggest sporting name, still,
he just turned 60, 61,
he's still a huge name there, very, very influential,
and he's a senator,
and he took me literally from minister to minister,
to minister, to the security minister,
to the closest advisors to President Putin,
and over a period of two years,
I shuttled backwards and forwards to Washington.
And then that day when Russia signed the deal,
so the last country of the 25 countries to agree it,
it was happiest day of both of our lives,
'cause we realized that we need to talk to each other,
we need to work together.
These global problems cannot be solved just by America,
or just by Britain.
Russia is a country and it operates in 11 times zones,
it go from Vladivostok all the way to Saint Petersburg,
11 time zones.
It owns half the Arctic.
It's got huge natural resources.
You think of China, what a massive country China is?
India.
We cannot solve these big global problems,
whether it be climate change, overfishing, pollution,
any of these without all these countries working together.
And that's why these environmental diplomats
are so important because they're able to work together
and listen to the dialogue of the other side.
Yeah.
And with that, we're on the cusp of COP26,
and in Glasgow, I think you're attending that.
Like, what is your hope for what may transpire there?
Yeah.
Well, my hope for COP26 is that finally we realize
that we're in the last chance, that we really are.
So what I saw in Greenland in terms of the melting
was so worrying, very, very, very worrying.
And I want bring my message by what I've seen there
and bring it to Glasgow.
Ice is essential for life on earth,
'cause what I started at keeps our planet
within a temperature range in which we can live.
And I always say to politicians, no ice, no life.
If we allow the polar regions to melt and we allow
the glaciers in the Himalayas to melt,
we will not be able to survive.
Ice is as important as the air we breathe.
And I'll go there with a message, please,
we cannot have these commit.
I cringe whenever I hear a world leader make a commitment
for 2050 and 2060, which a lot of them are making now.
There's no political leader or business in the world
that won't make a commitment for 2050, 2060,
and we know perfectly well they won't be around there
to deliver on it.
We need shorter commitments,
but not only the commitments, we now need action.
The time for talking, talking is important,
getting consensus is important,
but the time for action is right now.
Yeah, it seems that the gravamen of the conversation
is around slowing this process down.
We had Paul Hawken on the show the other week,
and he said (laughs) he said, "Nobody gets up
"in the morning excited about mitigation, right?
"We need to be talking about draw-down, like reversing this.
"We need to invest in these regenerative solutions."
And yet from a political perspective,
that becomes problematic,
and the safest route is always to talk
about this mitigation idea
or how we can reduce these emissions
as opposed to really, in my opinion,
overinvest in the solutions that will be most impactful
in terms of draw-down and this idea of regeneration.
Well, the interesting thing is if we miss the time now,
so if we allow, just to put this in perspective,
we're going into what's called UN COP26.
So COP26 means there've been 26 of these conferences.
They've lost it 27 years.
Okay?
So a large portion of the world's population were not alive
when we started these negotiations to try and put a halt
to the climate crisis.
Okay?
And if we miss this opportunity,
and if it's just a talking shop,
then no amount of political goodwill,
no amount of technology which you talk about,
no amount of investment is gonna be able
to solve this crisis because you pass as a scientist,
say certain tipping points,
and there are a number of scientists who believe
we have already passed some tipping points in terms
of the Greenland ice sheet.
If the whole Greenland ice sheet were melt,
that's a seven-meter sea level rise that impacts everybody.
Yeah, we've seen the floods, like you said,
in Europe, we saw floods in New York City,
it wasn't even a hurricane and it caused
the catastrophic floods, killed dozens of people.
We've seen these climate events happen.
In Greenland, originally you were thinking
of a bigger swim of swimming the entire length
of what has receded,
a part of the ice sheet that's already melted.
Correct?
What was that number again,
like since from the beginning of the COPS from 27 years ago?
Yeah.
So initially in a...
I've always got an Atlas opening in my office,
and I'm always looking at and thinking to myself,
where can I do a swim here
that's gonna highlight an issue, be it pollution,
be it climate change, be it overfishing?
Where can I do a swim?
And creativity is not an aha moment.
It's an, a duh, moment.
It means, uh, why did I not see this great swim?
And so there was a moment when I thought, wow!
Why don't I go to Greenland and do a swim in Ilulissat
and start where the glacier
was 27 years ago and swim all the way to where it is today?
That was a bit naive of me because there's so much ice
pouring down, it's literally like a wall of ice,
so much ice now coming down
that that swim wouldn't have been possible.
So as soon as I got there,
I realized that I had to swim across it
rather than do something like that,
which would have been, frankly,
would have been a lot easier to tell as a media story,
this is where the glacier was 27 years ago,
and there it is all the way up there now.
Yeah, it's several kilometers, right?
Or several miles?
Follows, since 100 years ago,
it's gone over 60 kilometers.
Wow!
So it's receded an awful lot.
And as I said, at the moment now, it's receding,
so it's moving at a speed of 14 meters per day in summer.
It's crazy.
It's truly astonishing.
The other thing that you notice when you're up right next
to the glacier as it's carving
is just how much water there is.
There are waterfalls coming on the side,
you've got water coming from the side,
you've got water coming underneath as I talked
about those lakes on the top,
you've got water draining through and coming out.
It is a very, very dynamic situation there right now.
And remember, this is just one glacier
on the west coast of Greenland,
but this is happening in many glaciers around the world,
in the Arctic, in the Antarctic,
and obviously in the mountainous regions.
And the mountainous regions are another scenario altogether.
And the reason for that is because those glaces provide
a constant water supply.
Mm-hmm.
So you think about the glaces in the Himalayas,
they provide water to India, to China, to Bangladesh,
to Burma, to Pakistan.
People need water.
Water is essential for life on earth.
And as those glaciers retreat, as a melt away,
there goes at water supply.
So those areas then become a cocktail for conflict.
People need to move to water.
You had mentioned that the Greenland swim
was among, if not the hardest swim that you had done.
Walk us through the experience of getting in that water.
I guess it was around zero celsius, correct?
And how you kind of trained and prepared yourself
to endure that and what it actually felt like
when you were (laughs) in that frigid cold.
Rich, the water is so cold,
(Adam and Rich laughing)
so it ranged between (laughs) it ranged
between zero and three degrees.
And swimming in cold water is the only sport
in the whole world
that the more experience you have, the harder it becomes.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
And the reason for that is, so let's just say,
you're playing tennis.
The more balls you hit, the easier it becomes,
what it should.
Okay.
With cold water swimming,
the more you do, the harder it becomes,
and that is because when you've been really, really,
really cold, you never forget it.
It's deep down in your bones.
And so every single subsequent you swim you're gonna do,
you have to forget about what happened there.
I had to forget about that swim in 2007
when I swim across the north pole.
I had to forget the panic
when I was swimming down in the Ross Sea
while gasping for air
in a glacier lake on Mount Everest,
you got to forget it and you've gotta be ready
for the new swim.
So the training package was a long package.
I then did the Acclimatization Iceland,
and then you arrive in Greenland,
and now I'm gonna get into the water.
And as I slowly lower myself down that ladder (chuckles)
it's just incredibly cold.
And early in the morning, I've taken a temperature capsule,
and what that does is it tells my doctor on the boat
exactly what's happening inside me realtime.
And the astonishing thing happens when I lower myself
into really cold water,
actually my core body temperature rises.
So it rises from normal core body temperature,
which is about 37, up to 38,
and then I normally swim for about 10 minutes,
and during that time,
my core body temperature maintain the same level,
and on some occasions even increased.
But then when I get out and the cold blood in my arms
and legs returns to my core,
then my core body temperature drops.
And so then it's quickly into a sleeping bag
and then a hot water, three hot water bottles,
hot chocolates, and it would take me
between two and two and a half hours to rewarm
after each of those swims, and I was doing it twice a day.
So after I'd finished my first swim, I'd recovered,
I'd eaten a bit of lunch, then back in again
for the second session.
It was unrelenting and it was-
So 10-minutes swims?
It takes two hours-plus to warm up from a 10-minute swim.
Correct.
And you're in.
And in the old days, I just used to dive in.
I used to dive in,
I used to swim as fast and as quick as I could, get out,
get into a hot shower.
We tried that in some of the training,
that is a worst possible thing you could do.
The science now is quite clear you need to lower yourself,
you need to be able to control your breathing,
not have what they call the cold-shock response,
and then once you're ready, get going,
and then swim as fast and as hard as you can.
Swimming's also the only sport in the world
which operates on three axes.
So your head moves left or right,
your arms move around and around,
your legs move up and down.
And if any one of those is not in sync,
you're gonna be fighting the sea.
But I can tell you something,
when you jump into zero-degree water,
things are not necessarily in sync.
And so there's this, you're fighting
when you're in that type of water.
It's a struggle.
It's a, you're constantly thinking about the pain,
and on the side of the boat, I've got my team counting me.
They're giving me my stroke counts.
If I'm going at 30 strokes a minute, they're happy.
If I got up to 34, they ask me to slow down.
If I'm done at 25, they say, if you don't speed up,
you're gonna be out very, very soon.
So it's a constant communication with my team to be able
to get me through each
of these swims.
Mm-hmm.
Given that no matter how much you do it,
it never gets easier,
there's nothing that you really truly can do
to acclimatize yourself or normalize the experience,
why even train ahead of time to get ready?
Is that just to figure out how to communicate with your team
and to get all the kind of data points
so that they can ensure that you're safe,
or what was your thinking with all of those swims
leading up to Greenland?
No, no, actually the acclimatization
is absolutely essential.
If I didn't do that, no, I don't think (laughs)
I'd be able to survive.
The water is so extreme.
Water is also a fascinating substance, Rich.
So obviously between zero and 100, it's a liquid.
Above 100, it changes, it becomes a gas.
Below zero, it changes from a liquid to a solid.
So there's actually a tipping point
at which everything changes.
And it's the same inside you.
So when you're swimming in water around zero,
and sometimes I've done some swims
below zero degrees centigrade.
So when I swim down to the Ross Sea and when I swam
at the North Pole, the water was minus 1.7.
So saltwater gets even colder.
And when you're in that water,
it is, you are on, you're definitely (laughs) on the edge
of life and death, no question about that.
So having done the preparation,
having done some of the acclimatization, it helped hugely.
But there's only so much you can do.
You're not gonna be able to acclimatize
and make it feel comfortable swimming in the Arctic
day after day.
And at the end of the swim, so it was 14 days of swimming,
I remember on the last day,
I was just about to low myself down the ladder,
and I'm just wearing swimming trunks, right?
My team are in three or four layers of clothing,
and I looked at them and I was really happy
'cause this was the final swim
and I wouldn't have to wake up in the morning
and get back in amongst the icebergs,
but all of them were shivering.
So everybody on the boat was cold,
and I realized that for 14 days,
I had been absolutely frozen.
Wow!
You literally had ice water in your veins.
Yeah.
(Adam laughs)
The uniform is obviously the open water swimming uniform
that you've kept true to, even though you could have done
these extreme events and nobody, or these extreme swims,
and nobody would have batted an eye
if you were up even a three mil wetsuit
or a seven mil wetsuit, but you're keeping
to the marathon suite, you're a member
of the Hall of Fame of Marathon Swimming,
you're keeping to the marathon swimming, just a Speedo,
swim cap and goggles, right?
Sure.
And it's for a few reasons.
So clearly, I'm trying to get attention to these areas
and to the issue of the climate crisis,
and you know perfectly well that if you swim
across the north pole in a pair of Speedos,
a cap and goggles, the world's media
are gonna (chuckles) follow you.
As I was arriving at the north pole,
I remember I had a satellite phone on the boats.
There was Jay Leno was calling me,
lots of big names are calling me,
I realized that the world's eyes were on me.
This was the first time in human history that the north pole
had properly unfrozen.
If I was able to do a swim there to carry a very,
very powerful message.
So that's one reason why I wear just a pair of Speedos,
but the other one is more fundamental,
and that is the decisions which world leaders
have to make now are hard,
they are complex and they require courage,
because we're asking them to make decisions now
and the benefits will be felt in a few years' time.
And I'm urging world leaders to speak courageous
because if we don't do that,
we're gonna be in an incredibly difficult situation
in a few years' time.
And if I'm asking for them to be courageous,
I also felt that I should be courageous,
and we felt that swimming in a dry suit or a wet suit
wouldn't send the right message.
What about a swim mask?
Have you considered a swim mask?
There's a whole inside joke about this.
(Adam, Luis and Rich laugh)
I get the answer for him.
Yeah, see?
See what I'm saying, Adam?
Adam goes out into the ocean and he refuses to wear goggles,
he wears a swim mask.
I keep giving a shit about it 'cause I don't understand,
like please, put on a pair of proper goggles.
Your neighbor, the Octopus Teacher Guy,
he, I don't know how close of a neighbors you are.
Yes.
Yeah, like a-
You guys don't even know what it is.
Okay, so you got much.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
So you've got much more visibility.
I just wear these things just, I don't know why,
just it's what I've always wanted.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
Well, you've been very generous with your time,
but I can't let you go as we kind of wrap this up
without asking you
if you have any advice for listeners or viewers
who are inspired by what you've done,
who feel compelled to participate
in positive, meaningful change,
what is your best suggestions in terms of how people
can get more involved in climate change issues?
What is the single best thing that they can do to help?
A few things.
Please, I can't really down to one,
but we need to become environmentally literate.
We really do.
We need to understand the issues,
and wherever I go in the world,
even speaking to heads of state or or business leaders,
it becomes quite clear to me
that they don't understand all the environmental issues.
We need to become on top of them
like we have with, for example, pandemics
in the last year, year and a half.
I think the second thing is we are way past the time
when we can be quiet on this issue.
This is the defining issue of our lifetime.
And the third thing is what can ordinary people do?
Every single decision which we make, every single purchase
which we make on a daily basis is a decision
about our future, it's a decision about our children
and the whole of the animal kingdom.
And whether that be the clothes we wear, the food we eat,
how we get to school, how we get to work,
how we invest any money which we may have, spare money
which may have, every single one of those decisions,
it's a decision about our future,
and I just ask everybody to be really cognizant
on a daily basis of those decisions,
because if we always choose
the environmentally-friendly decision or choice,
then multiplied over 7.9 billion people,
which is the world's population,
that makes a really big difference.
Mm-hmm.
Yes.
It really is up to us.
Excellent.
Yeah, yeah, and-
The idea
of being self-empowered in this process.
And that's what's so good about us being able
to come together and talk about the environmental issues
and the climate over and over again
as we to build the environmental literacy.
So, you're so eloquent, always, Lewis,
and you're an incredible diplomat for the oceans.
It's really a pleasure to speak with you.
I so wanted to be one of those people huddled up
and shivering on the boat while you had to get in the water,
but this is the next best thing.
I wouldn't have allowed you.
(Adam laughs)
Yeah.
I wouldn't have allowed you, you would have had to-
I would have been in there.
Hey, you said you're done with ice swimming.
You said that on your Instagram, that you think you're done,
you think you're retired.
How sure are you about that?
Very.
(Adam and Rich laugh)
But not 100%.
Now, well, yeah, not 100%, but as I said,
I've been doing this for 15 years, and in some cases,
I've literally felt like a voice in the wilderness,
actually in the wilderness.
And I love swimming.
I want swim until the last day of my life.
When I'm swimming, the world feels perfect.
I love at the end of the day,
running down into the ocean and running down the beach
and taking off my clothes and jumping in the sea,
and those first 10, 20 strokes is heaven,
and I'll continue to swim,
but swimming in the polar regions,
which is so incredibly dangerous
and which is so all-consuming,
I think it's gonna be a new generation
that I hope will take up the baton and be a voice
for the polar regions and important they are.
Keep on swimming, I'll be swimming in some
of the warmer parts of the world.
I'll still be talking about overfishing, climate change,
plastic pollution, which is so endemic all over the world,
I'll keep on swimming until my last day.
Well, the world is certainly better
with you swimming in it.
As Adam said, you are a phenomenal champion
of our precious waterways,
and my only regret in this experience today
is that we couldn't do it in-person,
so if you find yourself in Los Angeles, open invite to come
to the studio, and we'll go deep and long,
and if I find myself in Cape town
or wherever else (laughs) you may be,
I would love to meet you in-person
and continue the conversation,
but appreciate you tuning in today, Lewis,
and best of luck to you.
Thank you both so much.
It's been a real honor.
Thank you.
Thanks.
(air whooshing)
Adam, what did you think?
I always love talking to Lewis.
He brings it every time,
and I always learned something from him.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, what a beautiful human?
I think we can all learn quite a bit from his example.
And again, this is a guy who's been doing it for 30 years,
and to maintain that level of not only enthusiasm,
but integrity and commitment
to communicating his perspective,
you would think that someone who's been at it for that long
would become jaded, and maybe deep down he is,
but the manner in which he carries himself
as this statesman diplomat, I think is really powerful.
The last 18 years in polar regions,
like, and I love what he said
about he opens up the Atlas to like look
for like the next project, and he's doing that already.
Right, well, there was a map behind him on the wall
the whole time, I don't know if you saw that,
and he had that polar bear statue.
Yeah, he did.
(Rich laughing)
But I love what he said about environmental literacy,
building environmental literacy and how that's kind
of a responsibility we should all take on.
And so kudos to you for doing that, for doing that
for so long in relation to climate with Paul Hawken
and then even stuff that we do
when it becomes kind of part of the new cycle,
even when it's not, we often bring it up.
But then also when it comes to plant-based,
that's a big driver in your conversation,
usually around plant-based eating,
'cause he spoke to individual choice a major thing
people can do.
Yeah.
I think the environmental literacy piece is huge,
but the caveat that I would offer on that topic
is the fact that literacy without action
is feckless, and what I mean by that
is when I'm thinking about that,
I'm reminded of something that Paul Hawken said,
which is that there's no difference between someone
who is incredibly climate-literate and somebody
who is a change denier
if they're not actually doing anything.
Yeah, right.
Right?
So the important thing is finding a manner
in which you can plug into the solution,
and that thing being the thing that excites you,
which again, hearkens back
to what Paul Hawken had to say,
like find the thing that gets you excited in the morning.
There's so many things, pick up Paul's book, "Regeneration,"
which is rife with all manner of solutions.
Find the thing that excites you a little bit and determine
a manner in which you can participate in that.
And I think a way to do that is even if you don't have
his new book, you can go to Paul's website,
regeneration.org, and he's got a function on there
called Nexus, and if you click that,
I think it's regeneration.org/nexus, if you wanna go direct,
and that's a way to learn more about the various ways
in which you can participate, but yeah,
it begins with literacy,
but literacy must be followed up with the action.
Yeah, and I think Paul Hawken and Lewis Pugh,
they're kind of two sides of the same coin, right?
Like one is in the, one is kind
of doing grassroots education work and the other one
is doing kind of a red alert exploration, activism
and diplomacy at the highest levels.
Yeah.
And they've both been doing it for decades.
Yeah, amazing to have those guys.
Yeah.
All right.
So let's switch gears for a minute here,
in kind of thinking about what we wanted
to talk about today, Adam and I, as you guys may know,
we kind of toss back ideas throughout the week,
we work on an outline, and in switching gears right now,
we're gonna try another thing
that's a little bit new rather than taking something
from the news cycle to dive deep into.
I wanted to telescope out a little bit,
because I've been thinking a lot about this podcast,
what I wanna say with it and what I want it
to be about in general, especially since I'm coming up
on the ninth anniversary of doing this,
this is the 631st episode,
and if you think about that in two-hour chunks, that's what?
Over 1,200 hours of talking.
So what are we doing here?
People always ask me, what have you learned?
How does all the information get processed in your head?
What are the biggest takeaways?
And like I said,
I have been spending a little bit more time devoted
to thinking about that because I've always felt
like I didn't really have a very good answer.
And this process of self-inquiry really was catalyzed
or prompted by dent of my visit to Minneapolis
this past spring,
and I've told this story prior, but just to briefly recap,
when Black Lives Matter was erupting and Derek Chauvin
was on trial for murder of George Floyd and Minneapolis
was on the precipice of burning,
it was a moment in time in which everybody had opinions
about what was right, what was wrong, what was happening,
and I certainly did,
but we made this choice as a team to actually visit,
like go to the place, and rather than form
our takes based on other people's opinions
or our siloed news feeds,
to instead like go there and create
a perspective that was informed by direct experience
rather than the news cycle.
And towards that and to engage with community leaders,
from people on the front lines all the way
to the actual mayor, and that was really fueled
by this sense of curiosity to engage in conversation,
and premised upon this idea that is fundamental
to the podcast here, which is that conversation matters.
Like it really does matter.
And the most impactful exchange
that I had over the course of that trip
wasn't with the mayor,
it wasn't with the city councilman
or any of the civic leaders that we sat down with,
but instead was with this average citizen,
this neighborhood watch volunteer in George Floyd Square
who in the course of conversation on the street
and this person like wondering who I was and curious
about my motives for being in George Floyd Square asked me
this question that turns out was quite profound
and not what I was expecting, which was,
"What does your podcast do?"
He literally said, "What does your podcast do?"
Mm-hmm.
And it seems kinda funny, like usually
it would be like, what is your podcast,
or what do you talk about, or tell me about it?
But something about that phraseology,
like, what does your podcast do?
Really forced me to think about an answer
because I didn't have an answer in the moment,
and I still struggle with trying to answer that question,
but I think that I'm starting to arrive at some sense
of what that answer or those answers are.
And I think in the most general sense,
the podcast is like this signal for change.
It's a signal for the positive change that I've experienced
in the sense that like whatever I've experienced
is available to other people, like this hopefulness,
and the positive change that I believe we're all capable
of manifesting as individuals,
as citizens, as a global collective,
and thinking about that makes me think about the audience
and this idea of putting that question on yourselves,
like where all of you?
Like, what does your work do?
What does your curiosity do?
What does your life do?
Like, what do you do?
And I'm not talking about your job,
I'm talking about like you, like, what are you doing?
Like, can you answer that question in your own life?
Like, Adam, what are you doing?
Like, like, what are you doing?
Not much.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
Right?
Like, what is the thing, man?
Like, what are you up to in the broadest sense?
Like, listen, man,
you're taking up a lot oxygen, what are you doing with it?
Exactly.
I know.
And it's kind of like midlife crisis inspiring stuff,
we're treading into that territory
because you can overthink your life,
and there's something to be said
for doing what's on your plate,
like doing what's in front of you, because for me,
I feel like best in my life when I'm kind of on a mission
or whatever, but that doesn't mean
that's what I should be doing or am doing,
it's just a way to engage your mind in a way.
I don't know.
A lot of people, the yogis would say,
what you're doing is you're here to learn and grow
as a human being, like that is the deal.
But of course,
we also have all these crazy tragedies kind
of seemingly unfolding in real time all around us,
and so is that enough to like, to navel-gaze?
Probably not.
So it's a good question.
If you ask me, what am I doing when it comes to my work?
The best, I've had three times where I feel
like there was meaning, like what I'm doing
like affects the world in a positive way,
not during the activism, four things,
not necessarily through activism, one was planting trees,
very simple, trees matter, we need more trees.
I did that for a living for three years.
The other was when I was doing Lonely Planet stuff,
I hyped up this small roadside, stand
that like ended up becoming this huge thing
as Lonely Planet drives so much traffic
and they've made a lot of money and put their kids
in better schools, and that's great.
The third thing is the work with David Goggins,
and the fourth thing is this work with you.
And that's where, those are tangible feedback I'm getting
from the world or obvious, like with trees.
So like other than that, on a daily basis,
what does your life do?
I don't know, I take a much more Zen Taoist approach
and I try not to think about (laughs) that.
Yes, well, it's tough.
It's so esoteric.
But I think there is, and I'm somebody
who hasn't, likewise who hasn't been super directed in that,
but I think there is something to be said
for indulging in that thought experiment,
because whatever comes up,
we'll allow you to be a little bit more directed in terms
of where you focus your attention.
And if you were to ask me
even not that long ago, like, what is your podcast?
It's like, I have conversations with people
that interest me, and that's kinda it,
like I never really probed it any more deeply than that,
but anniversaries, middle-age or having been somebody
who's been doing this for nine years, like, you start
to think like, well, what are we actually doing here?
Like, why am I spending so much time on this?
Like maybe I should be a little bit more thoughtful
and intentional about how I'm approaching this work
and trying to find ways to hopefully make it more meaningful
for the audience rather than just indulgent.
And so in that process of rumination,
I've arrived at a collection of things,
right now it's six things, and that's a list
that may grow longer, at least I'm iterating on,
and that I'm kind of using as the basis for writing this.
The prompt was really like I'm being asked to go out
and do more public speaking.
And I have a keynote that I've delivered over the years,
and it's really about like my journey, it's about me,
it's about my story, it's about personal transformation
and addiction and plant-based nutrition and all of that
and the athletic accomplishments, but that feels
like expired on some level.
Like I understand it has value and people enjoy hearing
that story and it is part of who I am,
but I've done all of this other work since then
that has not been part of how I communicate with audiences
on stage, and I really wanted to figure out
how to make sense of the podcast in terms
of what can be conveyed in a keynote-type situation.
So I've been actively engaged in trying
to extract principles that I've learned over the years
doing the podcast that might be helpful to audiences
and making it relevant.
So that's kind of what motivated me to think
about all this kind of stuff,
and I thought it would be cool on "Roll On"
to drip these ideas out over the upcoming months,
like doing one at a time.
So the one that I wanna talk about today,
the focus of this is curiosity,
curiosity being a principle that has driven my enthusiasm
for doing the podcast in the first place,
and something that I think
is part and parcel of every interesting person
that I've ever sat across over the years,
and the principle really is that life expands in lockstep
with the extent to which you invest
in your own personal curiosity,
meaning that curiosity isn't this God-given disposition.
Now, he's curious, she isn't, it's not a personality trait,
it's more like meditation or training or education.
It's a practice.
It's a habit.
It's something that is abundant and something that grows
in proportion to your commitment to cultivating it.
And when you exercise it, in my experience
and in observing other people who invest in curiosity,
I have noticed that it will dramatically expand the aperture
of your life experience by putting you
in much closer contact with new people, new ideas,
new opportunities, adventures, practices,
relationships, that hold the potential to irrevocably
and positively alter the trajectory of your life.
I think what happens
is people confuse passion with curiosity.
People ask me all the time,
like how do I figure out what my passion is,
or I need to be living a life of passion?
You hear that all the time,
like pursue your life of passion.
But, and I think a lot of people are not connected
to their passion and it makes them feel bad
about themselves, like all these people
are out here pursuing their passion,
like, I don't even know what my passion is.
And you kind of feel lousy like, or guilty,
like I should know, and I don't.
Or that your job is supposed to be connected to it.
And I think it's, and I understand that,
like, I'm very empathetic to that,
and I've been that person for many, many years,
and the way out of that is to forget about all of that
and instead think of it in terms of curiosity.
Ask yourself, what is it that you're curious about?
And it doesn't have to be any big deal.
It could be some video you saw on YouTube
that piqued your interest in some, and prompted you
to like look more deeply into something.
So I think it's about awareness and presence of mind
to notice your curiosity as it naturally percolates up,
and then having the wherewithal to see that and say, oh,
there's a little spark of curiosity.
Yeah.
Maybe I should recognize that and honor that
by going a little bit more deeply.
And I think developing that habit,
just like a muscle that you build, will lead you to places
you perhaps can't really predict right now.
I like that idea,
like the idea, 'cause I think for most people,
curiosity is kind of like part of the firmware.
You know what I mean?
It's like, it's like in there,
but you don't really call it out as an individual thing,
and what you're doing is you're saying,
we all have that quality somewhere in us,
not everybody has exercised, like you said,
but even recognize it as a quality
that you have intrinsically and it itself does a lot, right?
It allows you to focus on just asking yourself the question,
the power that comes with that, that comes out
of what am I curious about?
Versus just kind of following
your curiosity unconsciously,
like you're saying, make it a conscious choice,
not an unconscious thing.
I do think smartphones can get in the way of it
like, 'cause then you're fed content.
Yeah.
Stuff pops up for you.
Yes, curiosity might take you left, swiping left or right,
that's not what you're talking about.
You're talking about a deeper inquiry within yourself.
I think that this media-saturated,
content-saturated environment we all live in kind
of is a, to what you're talking about.
So there would be turning off one to kind of turning on
the other aspect to this, I think.
I think that's where curiosity starts
to tiptoe into imagination, and they're certainly kindred,
but there are different things.
I think what you're talking about
is really about imagination, and you need
that open, quiet space to indulge that.
I think curiosity is about directing the imagination,
and I think the smartphone can be a tool.
It's just about your relationship to the smart, like, okay,
I'm curious about this,
the smart phone is a vehicle for learning more
about a particular thing.
It's just a question of whether you're in command of it
or whether it's in command of you and recognizing
what that relationship looks like.
And I just think
that when people say like, I don't know what my passion is,
it's like, I can't, I don't know how to help that person.
I can't tell you what your passion is,
but I do know that you can't find your passion
or your purpose or find meaning or fulfillment in life
without consistently applying curiosity,
and that just begins with those questions
that you're asking yourself, what are you curious about?
Mm-hmm.
And I think curiosity is something that, you're correct,
is innate within all of us,
but it needs to be called out consciously.
It needs to be developed.
It needs to be nurtured and cherished, and it begets itself.
Like the more you invest in it, the more curiosity you have.
We'll look at Davy's running journey, right?
Yeah, he is curious about what he can do and then look
what he's doing, and that opens up more questions.
Wait, well, if I can do a half marathon in 133,
how fast can I run it?
Right.
Or-
But behind it all,
what's really going on is if I train for a half marathon,
then I can give my excuse to buy a bunch of running shoes.
If I train for a marathon, then I can continue.
I can double down-
His sneaker.
It's the HYPEBEAST addiction rearing its head,
shrouded in this healthy pursuit of marathon glory.
(Adam laughs)
The sneaker-
Adjust, but it's true, that it's true,
and I think, yeah,
it's this idea of not needing to know the destination,
it's just about respecting the spark and following it.
And part of the fun or the allure
is not knowing all the answers or what the next step is,
and just opening yourself up to possibilities.
Where do you think this like connects to beginner's mind?
'Cause I always think people who stay young are the ones
that wanna learn another language
or do something different, or like start square one
in some skill, curiosity is a part of that, right?
Of course.
A perfect example would be Mary Kay doing the bike leg
on the marathon or the Malibu Triathlon this past week,
and like she's not an, she's always, Alexi
was explaining this really well, saying that Mary
is somebody who has always been the best and stays
with the thing that she's best at,
like she's just an incredible runner.
Right?
And the cycling piece has been an opportunity
for the first time in a very long time for this person
to have that, to like engage the beginner's mind,
to be a beginner.
And what I saw was somebody who was really like joyful
in that process, when you let go of like, I need to know
like, what are people thinking, or any, like,
let go of all of that and just allow yourself
to like go on this exploration of learn something new
to like have fun.
She didn't even have like a proper cycling kit.
Like she's an elite athlete, didn't even have
like a proper cycling kit, it didn't matter.
It was about like, we're having fun,
I don't know what I'm doing,
like I got a flat and I had to get the Tokyo golden medalist
to fix my bike (laughs) before I could even ride it,
and like, that's beautiful.
Yeah.
Right?
There's like a, there's a joy,
a release in the curiosity, right?
When you start to pursue.
Yeah.
So the message is to really bring that
into your conscious awareness, this idea of curiosity,
and to really be conscious of discontinuing that proclivity
or predisposition that so many of us have to build that wall
of security and comfort around yourself, right?
To rediscover the childlike mind
of the inquisitor, to ask yourself what's left to discover
and to really invest in discovering things
that you want to know, because it's curiosity
that really holds the answer.
I thought it killed the cat.
Yeah.
I don't know about that.
Yeah, I don't know.
Who came up with that?
Some cat hater.
So curious George thing to-
A dog person.
Curiosity killed the cat.
(Adam laughs)
That was-
Like, what a terrible message to be put
into some children's, young person's thing,
like shaming people for their curiosity?
Well, it was more like probably to keep people safe,
like, don't go out there, don't go in here.
Curiosity killed the cat.
Yeah.
That's a horrible thing to say.
It is horrible.
Don't be curious.
Right.
Be very afraid.
It's like we were watching "Romeo and Juliet,"
the Basil, version.
Aha.
And I was just thinking
that I could make a living on TikTok
just like if I could just give certain characters
some advice at crucial moments,
like all the best literature would be gone,
but these characters would survive.
So give me an example.
Like for instance, Juliet, you've only gone out
with him twice, both in the same night.
(Rich laughs)
You meet him,
you meet them at the fish tank in the movie, right?
In the play, there was no fish tank,
but you meet him at the party and then you have your moment
and then he comes later to your balcony.
So I'm gonna give you two dates.
It's probably one day, but I'll give you a two dates.
And then the next day, like you meet with them again
only for the second time or third time,
and you're supposed to marry the guy?
Right.
Like that's bad.
That's not good parenting.
I think this,
what I'm hearing here is curiosity leading you to building
a viral TikTok account of you breaking down
great literature and talking sense.
Poor choices.
Like I know we all have decided that "Romeo and Juliet"
is a master work of genius,
but let's like really break this down and analyze
like how prudent these choices really are.
Really bad choices.
(Rich and Adam laughing)
Relationship advice in Shakespeare.
Like I'm curious, I have this idea for all,
and I've been afraid to pitch you,
but what if we just sat around and talked
about our deepest regrets?
(Adam laughing)
Mm-hmm.
I thought that's what the show was already about.
(Adam laughing)
No, I have this idea though for my Twitter
'cause the Twitter is just kind of out there.
It's like fumbling.
I'm curious, I would like listeners to weigh in,
should I turn it in just to a reading Twitter account?
Like what I've read five days a week, that's it,
something I've read,
or should I just leave it as this grab bag of nothing?
I don't know.
I think you should try new things.
I think you should try it out.
Yeah.
All right.
Why not?
That or like some sporting news thing.
What should it be?
No, don't do that.
All right.
Curiosity killed the cat.
Yeah,
I could do that.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
I think it should just be, I think
it should be hot takes on Shakespeare.
Hot takes, poor choices
in our canon of great literature.
Yeah.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
Ah.
Is that what you meant by your curiosity?
I don't, listen, man,
wherever your curiosity takes you.
It took us to-
Curiosity empowers the cat.
We've volunteered at a marine rescue,
wildlife rescue up the street from you,
and we fed and helped clean up after beach sea lions,
and we did all that kind of stuff,
and that was based on just pure curiosity.
Like there's no, like we volunteered
for a whole season doing that,
was one of the best experiences I've ever had.
I think you're right.
I think there's a lot to it.
It's potent.
Yeah.
Good.
Well, there we have it, curiosity.
Curiosity, this is the title of this podcast,
"Curiosity Did Not Kill The Cat."
No, not yet.
Curiosity expanded the cat's awareness.
Curiosity is the cat.
There you go.
There is no cat.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
All right, we're devolving.
Let's get to listener questions
so we can get out of here.
Let's do it.
We're gonna San Francisco for the first one.
(air whooshing)
Hi, Rich and Adam.
This is Hadar from San Francisco.
Thank you for the wonderful podcast.
I love listening to it on long runs.
I'm calling to ask a question about getting into triathlon
or multi-sport from the swimming side.
I'm semiretired marathon swimmer
beginning to get into multi-sport,
and what I see around me are triathletes who get
into the sports as seasoned runners and bikers,
and my sense is that swimming is qualitatively different
than the two other sports.
And I wanted to ask if you had any advice.
Thank you.
(air whooshing)
Thank you for the question.
Yes and no, in terms of difference,
I think that you're in a fantastic situation in terms
of pivoting to multi-sport.
Most multi-sport athletes do not come
from a swimming background.
They certainly aren't semiretired marathon swimmers.
So you're leagues ahead of most people when they pivot
into the multi-sport arena.
Having that swimming background is a huge advantage
and fundamental to your success.
I think swimmers understand a couple key core things
that will serve them as multi-sport athletes,
not the least of which is they understand how to suffer.
If you're a swimmer who' trying to be the best swimmer
that you can be, you're no stranger to sensory deprivation,
like putting yourself in a position
where you're blocking out everything around you
and you're connecting with nothing
but your breath and your body movements
and pushing yourself.
So that's something that's very familiar to you
at this point.
A lot of multi-sport athletes get into it,
they've never really done anything hard,
so you have that experience under your belt.
You also understand and appreciate the importance
of technique, technique being crucial in terms of success
as a swimmer, and that appreciation to detail
in what it takes to become proficient in your stroke
will really serve you in terms of the intentionality
that you bring to learning how to properly ride a bike,
what your cadence looks like, your running form,
all of these things are already built into your DNA
and aren't things that you're gonna have to learn.
So I think swimmers make for great multi-sport athletes
because of their backgrounds,
and there's something about brain plasticity
that makes it so much harder for somebody later in life
to really understand how to swim well.
Like it's just, I don't even know if it's possible.
Like once you've reached a certain age threshold,
trying to teach stroke technique to older athletes
becomes very difficult, but cycling and running,
we've all run our whole lives,
so we already have background in that,
and cycling is very easy to teach,
and success in cycling is very much,
I don't wanna be too binary about it,
but you can learn how to ride a bike older in life
and you can get good at it by dent of saddle time,
and the technique will come along the way.
So having the swimming piece already locked down
makes your transition really smooth, I think.
Also because it tends to be a way to get ahead, right?
Like often, like if you're experiencing good at swimming,
you're way ahead than some of these people
who might then catch you.
(Adam laughs)
Sure.
The problem is like swimming, if proportionality-wise,
like swimming gets such a-
Small park.
Yeah.
It's like none of these races are oriented
around parody between the three sports.
No, but-
Swimming becomes a footnote.
Well, swimrun is different.
Yeah, swimrun is different.
Yeah, yeah.
Triathlon specifically, though,
the swimming is almost irrelevant.
(Rich laughs)
Yeah.
Ultraman is the one race where swimming
can kinda make a difference,
but for the most part, it's just about like staying
within range and then everything else makes up for people
that aren't good swimmers, and they allow you
to wear wetsuits in terrain
where I think that they should just say no wetsuits,
for the most part.
Mm-hmm.
So it really coddles the non-swimmer,
swimrun is different for sure.
But I'm excited about this journey,
and I think that if there's anything that you might need
to pay attention to that might be new coming
from a swimming background is that you have to give,
especially with running, you have to give your joints
and your ligaments time to adapt to the load,
swimming because you're in this suspended environment,
it's very easy on your joints and your ligaments,
so you can push yourself really hard.
Right.
You can recover quickly and you don't have to worry
until you get into like tendonitis for shoulders
and stuff like that with severe overuse injuries,
you don't have to concern yourself
with (clears throat) your knees hurting,
any of the kind of stuff that comes with running.
So you have to build your volume in running much more slowly
and diligently than you would have to do with swimming,
so paying attention to that,
like your lungs and your heart will acclimate and become fit
much more quickly
than like your body's infrastructure's ability
to adapt to that load.
So even if you feel fit and you wanna run longer
and you feel like you can,
you have to err on the side of caution
to prevent those injuries from occurring.
So I think exploring that and learning a little bit more
about what that looks like for you will save you time
benched from injuries,
but I think if you're like me,
you'll develop a love and appreciation
for these other disciplines,
and it will also renew your love for swimming.
Like when it's not just all about swimming and you get
to mix it up and have this variety,
then you look forward to your swims rather than dread them
like a lot of swimmers do who have been at it
for a very long time.
Great stuff.
We'll move on.
Tyler from Florida.
I have a Florida man for you.
Mm-hmm.
Florida man, question from Florida man.
(air whooshing)
Hey, Rich and Adam, this is Tyler from Florida.
So my question is a morality question.
I am a 31, soon to be 32-year-old,
and the moral topic that I am inquiring about today
is on money.
I used to believe that money was somewhat of an evil thing,
and I've since shifted to believe that money
is simply a tool, and once I amass enough of this tool,
then I can retire from the things I do not want to do,
AKA my job now,
which would then allow me to do things that I want to do,
such as work on issues, such as food sovereignty,
food security, climate change and the like.
So my question is, and I know the answer is a very nuance,
but would you suggest someone like myself
to make as much money as I quickly and ethically can
in the next four to five years
to them be able to, quote, unquote, retire from the system
to then devote my time solely on social justice issues
that matter to me?
Because I simply don't think I had the mental capacity
for both at the same time,
because I've seen it.
When I focus on social issues,
my job suffers, and when I focus on my job,
my impact on social issues suffers.
So, yeah, if you could help me figure out my life,
that would be great.
Thanks, Rich, thanks, Adam.
(air whooshing)
I appreciate the question.
I'm not sure I can help you figure out your life, Tyler,
but we're gonna give it a shot.
Let's give it a shot.
I think that the first thing is understanding,
as you astutely pointed out, this is a nuanced thing.
So you need to break free of this binary thinking
like it's either or like my job or social justice,
or make money or don't make money.
Instead, think about money as energy,
not a thing, and approach it from an abundance mentality,
in other words, not like a lack, like if I do this,
then I won't have money,
if I do this, then I'll have a lot of money,
but I'll save it and then I'll use it for this.
Like think about it, try to hold onto it
a little bit more lightly and in a non-binary sense,
and I think it will allow you to broaden your perspective
on your current capacity.
I'm not a fan of staying in a situation
that is not serving you to accumulate resources
so that you can do something later.
I understand there's a prudence and responsibility in that,
but in terms of a philosophy of life,
I don't think that it's a good guiding force.
I've seen this play out many times
over many years with a lot of people,
and generally what happens is the person becomes calcified
in their lifestyle and rarely if ever reaches
that inflection point where they're ready to retire
and deploy those resources that they've accumulated
in some kind of socially responsible manner.
I'm not saying it doesn't happen,
but it doesn't happen as frequently as you might think.
And as somebody who went to law school with a lot of people
who said, I'm gonna do the law firm thing for a year,
I need to pay off my loans,
and then I'm gonna go do the thing that inspired me
to go to law school in the first place,
I'm sure that only a tiny percentage of those people
have actually made good on that aspiration
because that's just the way that life works.
Right.
So I would caution you against that strategy,
and I would encourage you to explore ways
in which you can indulge that aspiration
to be more service-oriented in your life in a manner
that is sustainable with maintaining your current job
and whatever level of responsibility that demands
that you stay in that job for however long.
It doesn't mean that any work or investment of time
that you make in the issues that inspire you or ignite you
or get you excited need to be at the detriment of your job.
Like there's ways to do it more sustainably,
so alleviate that pressure on yourself.
It's almost like my intuition is that you need to feel
that pain point.
Like if I'm going out there and making a difference,
my job is gonna suffer because I need to do it
in this particular way that requires that my job suffer,
and I think there are methods of effective altruism
that would allow you to be engaged in productive solutions
without having that downstream impact on your job.
Like even if you gave away $100 or $20 a week
or a month to one of the nonprofits
that has been approved of in the effective altruism world,
you're making a huge difference without requiring any
of your time.
So it's about broadening your thinking in terms
of around what that work looks like while also finding ways
within the construct of your job to spark that curiosity
that you have about these issues and find ways
within the confines of your free time to explore them.
100%.
I don't think there's any reason to wait.
There's things you can do.
You could go to beach cleanups, you can go to a protest,
you can organize an event and you can organize a teaching.
There's things you can do on weekends
that wouldn't necessarily impact your job.
If you don't like your job
and you don't wanna do it anymore,
that's a different conversation.
Right.
And you can be putting energy towards shifting
your career focus.
Right.
Like you had said before,
like if you have responsibilities, family, mortgage,
you might need to create a runway for yourself
to be able to off-ramp,
but I also don't like this idea
that like how much money you're gonna make
if you do one or the other.
Right.
Like you actually don't.
Like if you have, say you're in the financial,
it sounds to me like you're in the financial world, right?
Sector.
Who knows?
But you might think hat that's gonna be the way
you'll make money,
but you don't know how bringing that brain
to the social causes and what might pop up in your mind,
what kind of things might come up for you creatively,
imagination-wise, entrepreneurial,
that will, you don't know.
No, you don't know.
The illusion is that there's some kind of security
in this certain job situation,
and if the pandemic has taught us anything,
or it's like, you don't know how long you're gonna be, yeah,
you don't how long you're gonna be alive.
Right.
You don't know how long that illusion
of security will hold itself up,
and this binary thinking of if I do, if I'm a do-gooder,
that I'll be poor, but if I seek security,
then I'll be financially stable, is also an illusion.
Right.
To your point, like, let's say you go, well,
I'm super interested in this ocean plastic problem,
and through the course of exploring your curiosity,
you meet somebody or you stumble upon an idea that leads
to some kind of entrepreneurial venture
that not only ends up cleaning out the ocean,
addressing this plastic problem,
but also makes you very wealthy in the meantime,
like I think it's about, I think your instinct
that is in the financial industry.
Another instinct that I have
is that it's about risk aversion.
Like, what is your relationship with risk?
Right?
And this feels like somebody who has a certain level
of risk aversion.
And I think if you address that impulse
or where that risk aversion is coming from,
you can begin to untangle the knot and look at this
from a broader, more nuanced, less binary view.
Beautiful.
All right.
Love it.
But it's great instincts, Tyler.
Thanks for the question.
Yeah, appreciate it.
Now we're closer to home.
Guy up in Pasadena.
(air whooshing)
Hey, Rich and Adam.
This is Jason from Pasadena.
I wanted to hear your opinions on something
that's been weighing on me a bit,
a little bit over the past couple of weeks.
Recently, I've been doing a lot of reflection
on establishing better connections with those around me
and spiritually with the earth and our connection to it.
So internally, I'm usually pretty pessimistic with a lot
of things, but on the surface,
I try to remain positive and hopeful about mine, our future
and the future of the planet.
My problem is it's getting harder and harder
to remain optimistic in a world that literally seems
to be falling apart.
So like right now, the Kaldor fire is scorching Tahoe,
and Hurricane Ida,
it's basically like laid waste to Louisiana,
and the Northeast has had just like unprecedented rainfall
during the summer of 2021,
just to mention a couple of things.
Usually I retreat out to the wilderness here in California,
but the vast majority of that is actually closed now
just with the threat of the wildfire.
So while in the past
it seemed like global warming was just hearing
about the Greenland ice sheet melting or something
like that, now it really feels kind
of like the apocalypse is upon us and the earth
is just raging across all parts of the globe.
So I guess my question is how do we remain hopeful
amidst this chaos while trying
to reestablish our innate connection with the planet?
Thanks again for all the podcasts.
It's really a bright light I look forward to every week.
Thanks a lot, take care.
(air whooshing)
That's a great question.
Mm-hmm.
I feel like it's a generational question.
I think it's something that is on all of our minds.
Like I have to cultivate my own optimism.
I think my set point is fairly pessimistic-
Oh, you mean generational,
like everyone feels this a little bit?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought you meant like millennials feel it, but no-
Well, I think there's a tweak on that.
I think there is something to be said about that,
like with gen Z and millennials,
like feeling this a little bit more,
and with that kind of a percolating resentment
about the generations that have preceded them
that created this crisis and this mess
that they're forced to contend with and charged
with the responsibility of cleaning it up.
And so I'm sympathetic and empathetic to the descent
into depression and hopelessness over the whole thing,
but hope and cultivating hopefulness,
I think is really important, and it's a choice, right?
And it's a guiding principle or kind of a litmus test
for how you approach everything and how you look at life.
And life is better when you're able to perceive it
through an optimistic perspective.
And in terms of how kind of functionally productive
and of service you can be, that's really calibrated,
I think, in lockstep with your ability to be optimistic.
So I think cultivating optimism and hopefulness
is important, understanding that change is possible.
Like again, that goes back to another guiding principle
or lightening rod of this podcast, like change is possible.
Like how many stories of people have I hosted over the years
where people have met unforeseen obstacles and overcome them
to transform their lives?
Or some issue that we thought was (clears throat) impossible
to navigate and we figure out solutions.
So I think the process for Jason begins with baby steps.
Like how can you participate in meaningful change
for yourself or for other people?
Or perhaps the stakes are low, but you're in a position
to actually do something beneficial for yourself
or for others.
And I think with each step towards something like that
that you take, you're able to kind of cultivate
that hopefulness and optimism within yourself.
Like make a small change for yourself,
make a small change for your local community,
go out and help another human being,
even if it's as simple as picking up the phone
and spending an hour listening to a friend
who's going through a hard time
even when you don't have a solution for that friend,
just being a sort of non-judgemental sounding board
for somebody else's pain is a huge service to do
for somebody else.
It's something that's gonna make you feel better
about yourself, and I think in turn, hopeful and optimistic
about the possibility for change when it comes
to trickier, more difficult problems.
You scale that up, of course,
and we're dealing with the existential threat
of climate change,
but I think mindset around how to approach these problems
begins in those lower-stakes environment
where you're creating that neuroplasticity
around your worldview and your perspective
about the possibility for positive change.
Mm-hmm.
Well said.
I agree with you.
I do think we all are feeling it.
It's impossible, like with the level of media saturation
we all live with, it's impossible not to notice these things
that might have other, like I think every time
has been a troubled time.
I think every time has had their generational issues
to contend with.
This one, this feels a bit more existential than most,
but also what makes it feel that way,
it is, but what makes it feel that way doubly so
is the amount of media we get
that is constantly in our heads.
So I understand why you feel that way.
I feel that way sometimes too (clears throat)
but there are, just because, there's, we don't always know
what's really happening.
For instance, there's someone I know
who has a fly fishing business
where I've just been connected
to you as fly fishing business in Tahoe,
and his whole business has been wiped out.
But it's not because Tahoe has been on fire.
So the Caldor fire's been on the outskirts,
but he's saying Tahoe's been actually beautiful,
and that it's, and it hasn't, like the wilderness
is still lovely and there's still, he is suggesting
that the media is wrong and it's hurting his business.
That doesn't mean that there aren't problems,
but the point is that there is, I don't even know,
I haven't talked to him yet,
but I've just been connected to him,
but the point I'm trying to make is within this terrordome
that we create in our minds,
we're overlooking this oasis of things are not as bad.
Mm-hmm.
You know what I mean?
And so somewhere, we have to start focusing on the things
that are positive, right?
That's the way forward, right?
If you can focus on things that are going well,
even as everything else seems to be dwindling,
that grows and your consciousness grows with that.
So I would say when it comes to despair,
focusing on beauty first
will help you, and focusing on things that are working
and synchronicity, and I think that could help you.
But I think you said it better than I've just-
Well, I think that's a good point.
I think it's a fair and accurate point.
Like the idea like, well, all these parks are closed,
so I'm gonna stay home,
but there actually are places that you could go,
or areas right in our backyard
where we, it doesn't have to be on a grand scale,
it can be on a small scale.
You just go down to the beach or go up on a hike
in the San Gabriel's or something like that
and try to connect
with that innate impulse
to be at one with nature, I think is important.
But I think on top of that,
and we talked a little bit about this earlier,
when I think about people who have been in this hunt
for a long time, the Paul Hawkens
and (clears throat) the Lewis Pughs,
these are guys who you would think
would be completely pessimistic at this point and hopeless
because they've been banging this drum (chuckles)
for 30, 40 years and it's only now that people
are even beginning to pay attention
to what they've been saying for a long time,
and yet what you find are two people who are highly engaged
in communicating around the problem,
highly engaged in solution-based discourse,
and more often than not, hopeful about humanity's ability
to finally get to a place
where we can overcome these problems.
Paul Hawken is all about solution
and he's so optimistic about humanity.
So again, in terms of trying to plug yourself
into some level of hopefulness around this,
Jason, go to regeneration.org/nexus and start exploring ways
in which you can participate in solution-based activism,
and I think that may alleviate that veneer of pessimism
that you're feeling and perhaps reenergize yourself
around the idea of being solution-based,
because we need everybody, we need all hands on deck
actively plugged in
to how are we gonna move forward collectively and optimistic
about our ability to solve the problem,
because the pessimism certainly isn't gonna solve it.
Mm-hmm.
Right?
And so we actually require you to step up
and shoulder the mantle of optimistic responsibility
in this moment,
and to share that with your peers and your colleagues
and your family and your friends.
There's a quote that Yogi, used to say,
although, I know that's (laughs) name anymore,
but, used to talk about it, when the pressure is on,
begin and it will be off.
And I think of that in terms of writing all the time.
Like when you have a deadline,
you've felt this with your own work deadlines,
when you have a deadline
and you just don't wanna get to it,
or something's stopping you or the procrastination
is heavier, or maybe you really still need
to do more research, whatever it is,
you don't really start right away,
and it just builds and builds
and it gets more and more uncomfortable,
as soon as you start, you feel so much better,
'cause the, so it's exactly what you're saying.
As soon as you take action,
even in this kind of tragic landscape that you're seeing,
and a lot of that is real,
I think that you'll feel more, you will be on your way
to feeling better about the world.
Yeah.
Well said.
Way to stick the landing.
Thank you, 'cause I fumbled a lot in the approach.
I thought you handled it beautifully.
Thank you.
That's a good place to finish.
Once again, we entered this conversation
thinking we wouldn't have more than 45 minutes to an hour
of stuff to talk about.
We might've broken our record for longest "Roll On Podcast."
(Adam and Rich laughing)
I don't know, and I'll say it again,
I always do like, is this working for anyone?
Like are we like way off-base here?
What does this podcast do?
What does this?
I don't, you know what?
I thought I knew before today's episode,
I am back to the drawing board.
I've no idea.
You've no idea.
Maybe we'll figure it out
two weeks from hence, a fortnight.
A fortnight?
A fortnight hence.
See you in a fortnight, mate.
Right on.
I feel good though.
How do you feel?
I feel great.
Cool.
Yeah.
Follow Adam on all the socials at Adam Skolnick
for all your shark content mask-wearing hullabaloo.
I don't know, I couldn't think of a word.
Yeah, hullabaloo.
Hullabaloo.
Yeah, that's-
There you go.
I'm gonna start a mask company called Hullabaloo.
That's good.
That's not bad.
Yeah.
I still think there's a market
for the Skolnick wearing mask, caricature, T-shirt, hoodie,
which just says Skolnick on it.
(Adam and Rich laughing)
We've gotta work on that.
Yeah.
You can follow me at Rich Roll in all the places,
although on TikTok I am, Iam, I-A-M, Rich Roll,
putting more and more content up on TikTok, so exciting.
Leave us a message
if you would like your inquiry queried, 424-235-4626.
For links to everything we talked about today,
visit the show notes on the episode page at richroll.com,
also a couple of links in the description below
if you're watching on YouTube.
On that note,
please don't forget to hit the subscribe button on YouTube,
Apple, Spotify, all the places.
What else do I wanna say?
I think that's it.
I wanna thank everybody who helped put on today's show,
Jason Camiolo for audio engineering,
production, show notes, interstitial music.
We have the added bonus of Cale Curtis, brother of Blake,
now on board to supplement our audio engineering,
so that's very exciting.
Blake, of course, mans the shop in terms of video.
We've got Dan Drake assisting on video,
also stepping up as our new Creative Director.
Jessica Miranda on graphics,
and we have, oh, and Daniel Solis as well, new guy.
We're building our team.
We've got so many people now.
This team is crazy.
Davy Greenberg on portraits today, half marathon runner.
He's given the thumbs-up over there,
as well as Grace and Wilder the crew.
Yeah, props to the crew too
for being able to be so flexible and come in
at different time early today.
Yeah, we came in early today.
Yeah.
But it's always like that,
and everyone's always enthusiastic.
You got a nice team here.
The team is solid.
You know who else is on the team?
Who was that?
Your boy D.K. for advertiser relationships.
We've got-
That's a beautiful name.
Yes.
He's man in the TikTok channel right now.
See, if that was my, if, was my last name,
it would be on a T-shirt already.
Right.
Yeah.
(Rich and Adam laughing)
Would he?
Yeah.
Selling out stadiums?
It is an epic last name.
And that's it.
The music is always by Tyler Trapper and Hari.
Thanks, so love you guys.
See you back here in a couple of days
for another epic episode.
Adam, I want you to take us out.
Peace, plants.
Almost there.
Almost there, almost there.
(air whooshing)
(energetic music)